[Music]
good to see you my friend good good to
see you
I've been looking forward to this for a
while yeah you and me both yeah man
thanks for making the trip all the way
out here appreciate it that is a
pleasure for sure I have to say that I
had an extraordinary experience doing
your show everything from top to bottom
was amazing and of course there's the
production value side of it I mean
you've got like this staff of people and
you've got like 2,000 cameras going in a
sweeping crane and it's all very
impressive you're running it like a
legitimate Network daytime television
show like at the highest highest level
so that's impressive but I think what
what really stuck with me and has really
pushed me and and made me think more
deeply about what I do is the
intentionality that you put into the
conversations that you have like there
is a lot of time and deep thought that
goes into what you want to accomplish
when you sit down with people yeah for
sure so elaborate on that a little bit
yeah that one started with if I was
gonna enter the space and start doing
something there were two things that had
to be true one I really had to deliver
value and this started for me as an
exercise of creating something that
would be valuable for my employees and
at the time that I started the show I
had 3,000 employees about 1,400
full-time in the rest part-time but I
had a lot of people and I had written
saying called the impact Theory belief
system and it was the 25 things anybody
needs to do to their mindset in order to
empower themselves to do whatever they
want and I had one overarching fear when
I wrote it that people would memorize it
but they wouldn't live by it and so
people would come up to me and they
would say oh like bullet point 14 is my
favorite or whatever and I'd be like I
don't even know what bullet point 14 is
I don't have it memorized and I'm living
by it but it isn't something that I
memorized and that was beginning to
become apparent that people could they
could remember the concepts but they
weren't necessarily putting them into
practice in their lives and so part of
it was
they're only hearing it from one person
they're only hearing it in one way and I
think that people oftentimes have to be
hit from multiple angles until the
analogy or whatever that really clicks
with them or they hear it at just the
right moment where they hear it from
somebody who just talks in a different
way and so really resonates and changes
their lives and that was always my goal
to change people and so I thought I'm
gonna start bringing people on this this
whole podcasting thing is really taking
off it's becoming something pretty
extraordinary so let me enter that in a
way that's gonna bring value to my
employees and that was sort of the
thought at the beginning and then I
thought well if we're gonna go to all
this trouble let's really do something
that will reach a broad audience and
then I thought okay well if I'm gonna do
that there are a lot of people doing
this but I just have a fundamental
belief that there's always room for the
best and so I wanted to come in and
bring something new and what was that
new thing that I could bring to the
table and I thought people go on and
they give the same interview over and
over and over and it's it's really
dictated one because they've got talking
points that they want to get across so
that's you know can be difficult to get
around but two people ask the same
question and so I thought what if I
could go watch essentially everything
that they've put out listen to every
podcast read their book do all of that
which would admittedly take an
extraordinary amount of time but could I
learn something new in that which
hopefully will improve my life could
that allow me to package this interview
up better for my employees and the
people listening to this and then could
I honor the guests with that so that
they really saw that I took their
knowledge very seriously I really wanted
to learn from them and then that I could
get them out of what I call their loop
so they're used to saying all these
things they've already given those
interviews probably certainly in the
beginning by the time they got to me
they probably already done ten other
interviews so I had to know their loop
so that I could build and this is where
the intros came from I could build an
intro that with all the love respect in
the world took that story away from them
so it had already been told at the top
of the yeah and that's not easy to do I
mean you have to there's certain people
come in and they're they have their
talking points and that's their goal
right they they want to communicate
those talking points and my strategy has
always been that's fine I will give them
that bandwidth but we need to exhaust
and move beyond it right and so that's
why mine tend to go longer and you don't
get into it until the later stages of it
because because people have to go
through that exercise right to get to
the other side but I mean you've done a
masterful job of that and I think
there's a lot packed into what you just
said but at a very high level top level
what you're doing is an exemplary
example of this incredible moment that
we're experiencing right now this
democratization of not just education
but you know powerful information that
holds the you know the potential to be
transformative for sure and it's cool to
be a part of that movement I often think
about you know what I what would I've
done when I was 18 years old or 16 years
old and I was struggling with who I
wanted to be and what I wanted to
express and what I wanted to invest my
time in and there just weren't the
resources that there are now so I don't
think that we can overestimate the
impact of this movement on what future
generations you know are gonna look like
which is cool dude I agree aggressively
and I think that we're still in the
beginning stages of what this is going
to become but this is really pretty
extraordinary one that people are
embracing long form and I remember when
I started I don't know if you got the
same feedback but everyone was like Tom
you cannot do an hour-long interview
that's crazy like no one is gonna listen
to that and I was like that's not true
for me certainly and I actually seek
things out that are longer and so we did
like the original episode that I did
with Tim Ferriss we broke it up into
four parts even though it was only an
hour long which now seems just
ridiculous but my team was just
convinced that it would never work and
my thing is like you were saying part of
this is you have to build rapport now
thankfully you and I have already done
an interview so dude when I sit down
ready you can take me as deep as you
want as fast as you want I will go there
but often times you have to like first
build that trust build the rapport live
in the interview as you're going and so
then the ends of the interviews tend to
be better because it's longer and you've
gotten to build a little rapport so that
just felt all true to me so we stayed
with the long format he
though at the time everything seemed to
run contrary to well the format lends
itself to being long-form and it's an
antidote to our short attention span
soundbite culture and I think there is a
deep you know you speak a lot about
mythology and I think it taps into this
thing that we all have within us to hear
a great story or you know or tell a
great story and if it is being well told
then there shouldn't be some kind of
finite time limit on it and I know for
myself when I'm listening to an amazing
podcast I'm frustrated if it if it's
short like I I'm I'm ready for it to go
as long as it needs to go to play itself
out and it's the one medium that you can
enjoy while you're doing something else
and it's not on television once and then
you miss it you can you can if you feel
like it's too long you can break it up
and enjoy it over time and yeah I got
that same feedback early on but I just
knew for a Maitai I just tried to I try
to have conversations that I would want
to hear and that I would enjoy and I
knew as a fan of the medium early on as
an early adopter that those were the
conversations that impacted me the most
and stayed with me over time yeah for
sure you know so in the another thing
you said is you were talking about these
fundamental principles that that you
divined and how people would point out
one or the other and yet there was this
gap between call it inspiration or
motivation and actual implementation and
that's where I really like to dig deep
into because I think there's a ton of
motivational content out there we can
look at an Instagram post and feel
inspired and it lures us into this false
sense that we've actually accomplished
something right yeah it's very different
to put that idea into action and I think
people you know sort of fall into this
place where they think they've
implemented it when they actually
haven't right and I know you're somebody
who said you know motivation is I don't
know what you said exactly overrated or
it's [ __ ]
so how do you think about traversing
that divide I think that everything in
life comes down to what your own value
system is so what's your identity what
are your beliefs what are your values
what are your haves with your routines
when you figure those out that like if
you just gave me a sheet that told me
what those were about somebody I would
tell you what the outcome of their life
is gonna be and for me
implementation being willing to face the
fears the anxieties the unknown the need
to stare at my inadequacies so I can
figure out what skills I actually need
in order to go and do something coz
implementation is really a question of
skill set so it that's why motivation
ultimately is going to let you down it's
like you may be motivated to go do
something but let me walk you through
exactly what will happen you're
motivated to try this thing which you
don't know how to do and you suck at it
and so you go do that thing you suck it
hurts your ego because your ego is tied
up in being right being good being
talented worthy all those like permanent
set states that people don't realize are
malleable and so they get stuck in that
it damages their self-esteem so they
want to run in the opposite direction
psychological immune system kicks in
reminds them that that was stupid anyway
why were they worried about even trying
that and so they back off and any one
time doing that's not a big deal it's
just that people do that over and over
and over and over and over and my thing
is that such a predictable pattern in
humanity it's like what do you have to
do to counteract that and the thing you
have to do is emotionally reward
yourself for being willing to take the
steps so okay I know I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna suck at it it's gonna hurt
it's gonna hurt my self-esteem and so
what do I need to do to make sure that I
don't trip up over that in a way that
makes me turn and run in the opposite
direction number one stop valuing myself
for being good at something and start
valuing myself for being willing to
learn so that's just a poor part of my
value system is I am a learner that's my
identity being willing to put in the
energy to learn and get better as a part
of my not only my belief system that
people can do it but part of my values
that that is important to do as a human
you should do that so when I see
something that I want to accomplish then
I know that I'm gonna have the fortitude
and the stamina to see that through
because it taps into my identity of the
learner and my value system of this is
important and should
done so then I just keep going down so I
hit the the wall of my inadequacy and I
don't meet that with stopping I meet
that with cool now I know what I have to
get better at I'm now aware of what the
skillset is and so now that I know what
skillset I need to develop and I believe
that it can be developed then I just put
the work into developing the skill now
the one thing that I think it's lost in
all of that is people lose desire and
they think that that means that oh it
wasn't as important as I thought it was
or I didn't want it as much as I thought
I did the reality is that even desire is
something that you have to learn to
cultivate to turn into a raging inferno
like your wants have to become needs and
I think there's some weird pushback that
people think that like if it's real if
it's love then there's no energy that's
put into building that up and I think
that's BS
so you think that that desire is a
teachable concept desire is definitely a
teachable concept the real question is
building that desire will that actually
work and so I think people have
something in their mind of something
they were forced to do that they didn't
enjoy and there was no natural
inclination towards that and I'll say
yeah you're probably never gonna be able
to build something there so that's like
trying to start a fire with wet moss it
probably is not yet happen but if you
have something where it really is a
spark of real interest it's not a love
it's not a passion but it's a spark of
real interest now that's something that
you can work with and really turn into
something by building it because there
is a process that goes along with
building that desire there is a process
that takes something from interest to
full-blown passion and if people are
willing to go along that process then
you really can evolve that initial just
sort of oh it's a spark of interest to
the very thing that I'm willing to give
my life over to completely and your
mindset for entering into that is is
this is this idea that you're a learner
right that you've cultivated some level
of self awareness around around this
concept so how did you arrive at that
and how can other people do the internal
work to figure out what it is that is
they're kind of internal barometer for
approaching personal growth so I'll give
people the the answer to the second
question first because it'll be more
usable and then because it's
entertaining I'll tell you how I came to
it which is unfortunately grotesquely
clumsy but what they should do is read
the book mindset by Carol Dweck I think
it's the most important book in the
English language bar none
it is old statement it is and I keep
waiting for flak on this but certainly
nobody that's read it pushes back they
may not agree but they don't think I'm
crazy
right and the reason that I say that
that it is that important is I can't
think of anything more foundational so
in terms of how to structure your belief
system in order to then leapfrog and
learn stuff and get out of your own way
so at a very simple level the book says
this there are some people who think
that their talent and intelligence are
fixed traits that's a fixed mindset then
there are other people who believe that
their talent and intelligence are
malleable traits that can be developed
and they're developed through challenge
and those are people the growth mindset
so people that believe they can grow
into basically whatever they want to
become do humans have limits yeah almost
certainly but there are such a gap
between where you are and the upper
bounds of human limitation that to even
worry about limitation just doesn't make
sense we put people on the moon so like
once you accept that we could figure
that out it's like you're not aiming at
anything crazier than that so it's going
to fall within the limits of what humans
can do so going after that and
developing that mindset and being aware
of what Carol Dweck calls the false
growth mindset which you alluded to
earlier where people think they're
thinking in the right way they think
they're implementing something but
they're really not so once you have that
so I wish I had read that book so it
would have made that all clear
unfortunately for me I had the like king
of all fixed mindsets and I was
convinced that my talent and
intelligence were fixed that it was just
about you know not what hand life dealt
me but playing that hand well and so to
play my hand well and even then I
wouldn't have understood what well meant
but I know how is acting and well in
those days for me meant feeling good
about myself okay so what age are we
talking about
early 20s and balloon so I'm wondering
whether that's entirely
intellectually honest because I do know
that
you were a young person you had this
goal of going to film school and
everybody told you that was not going to
happen and you were intent on making it
happen and you made it happen so on some
level if you were if you were if the
messaging that you were on the receiving
end of was you don't have the talent you
don't have the resume whatever it is you
had enough of a growth mindset to decide
to overcome that signaling or was that
just pure competitive I'm gonna show
them it wasn't a growth mindset at all
but it was that I believed that I was
talented so I believed in myself enough
to think oh I have the talent to do this
now I deep fears that I was wrong about
that and that plays itself out and you
see it in people's lives where they're
really going for something but you can
see when they're not making it they're
like in panic mode because they think
that means something about themselves
other than they're just still more
skills to gain so at the time I had the
belief that I was a that I had god-given
talent and so I believed that a word
about belief come from my dad made an
offhanded comment when I was 12 that I
ran with for the next like 10 years
which was he and knowing my dad may have
actually just been trying to save me
from embarrassing myself so what he said
was his actual words now that I play
them back were I think you're actually
better behind the camera than you are in
front of the camera now he may have
meant hey you should stop trying to act
or any should get behind the camera but
the way I interpreted it in my
twelve-year-old mind was you're really
talented behind the camera now
admittedly in the little movies that I
was making with my friends with a VHS
camcorder which I mean when I think
about what it is compared to today it
was crazy but I knew where to put the
camera to make it funny and funny was my
only goal back then and I was
legitimately funny so you take the the
initial wins that I got excited I don't
think we're blank slates so and I think
that some people think that's my
mentality Oh Rob blank sites you can be
whatever you want I think that the
degree to which you can change is so
profound it's probably better just to
think of yourself like that even though
it's not actually true so I have
predilections and I've always gotten
disproportionate gains anytime I put
energy into
verbal skills or written skills I would
get disproportionate response so me and
the next person could spend the same
amount of time the same amount of
intention and ferocity and I would just
get a little bit better than they did at
anything related to verbal or words or
writing and so because of that I was
really focused in the early years on
things were verbal so I wanted to be a
stand-up comic I did stand-up comedy for
a long time
I've been in like young author programs
in Speech and Debate since I was you
know 11 or somehow so for sure I got
very extroverted for somebody who
characterizes themself as an introvert
will now help me process through this so
then I for sure would have told you I am
the extrovert of extroverts now either i
misidentified that or I have changed
over time and I honestly don't know what
the truthful answer is but now for sure
I I am not in any way shape or form
drawn to social situations
I want to retreat I am a terrible
networker so people mistake a persona
that I use the ability to speak onstage
because it's a skill that allows me to
do what my truest deepest desires which
is to help people so I want to impact
people I want to see them go on the same
kind of transformational journey that I
went on but when I think about what
gives me massive anxiety it's getting up
and speaking in front of people even
doing a podcast like this like these are
things I've had to learn to manage and
myself I'm just not drawn to them I like
to be alone when you said you'd like to
be hermetically sealed in your space
dude that resonates with me emotionally
in a way that you can't imagine right
well let's take it back
paint me the picture of young Tom so
young Tom found my space in the family
was to be the peacemaker and to be the
comedian so that was the way that I
could have a unique voice it was the
youngest in my family I remember asking
my mom one time I was I was funny when I
was a kid right and she said you were
busy and I was like that's not funny
that's not the same thing and so as a
kid I definitely my identity was being
funny making people laugh that very much
carried through my high school years and
in high school I basically did like an
impromptu comedy routine five days a
week around my lunch table with the
9 or 10 other guys that and I did that
every day and what was there a driver
behind that was that he's here yeah a
lot of a lot of comics say you know it
was a it was their way of distinguishing
themselves or overcoming some sense of
awkwardness or trying to find a way to
fit in to the social circle 1,000% so I
was emotionally weak so and I found that
being funny stop me from getting picked
on by bullies so that was rad I could
make them laugh and I would defuse it
and I remember there's this really
gigantic guy in my school like pituitary
tumor big I mean just crazy big and he
said one time don't pick on Bill you
he's funny
so it that became my defense mechanism
so if somebody wanted to fight or the
typical teenage things I would just
defuse it by being funny because I was
terrified absolutely terrified that I
was just gonna get beaten up and because
I didn't know how to fight and was too
emotionally weak to deal with pain that
I didn't learn to fight or anything like
that so that sort of insecurity about
how to navigate my way through that I
did with humor it matched up with my
value system I didn't think less of
myself I thought wow this is a great
strategy I can talk my way out of things
and so by being funny I got left alone
which was great and so none of that was
like an issue for me I didn't grow up as
the kid that was picked on or anything
like that that wasn't part of my
identity so and I loved being able to
make people laugh made me feel good
about myself so and part of that was
driven by the people that I was really
close to growing up I believed they were
much smarter than me so I always felt
dumb because I felt dumb I needed
something to be better than them at so I
could feel good about myself and I was
just funnier than mm-hmm and this this
you mentioned that that you were the
Peacekeeper or the peacemaker was there
strife or conflict in the house or it
didn't seem like that at the time I mean
looking back three weeks after I left my
dad moved out so clearly there was
something going on and when he left he
said that he had been unhappy for 10
years so that puts me at 8 years old so
from the time that I made there's
something going on I certainly didn't
understand it when he left it took me by
surprise but is it possible there was
that my dad was very distant
for me emotionally so was that and I
considered him to be funny so was that
me trying to emulate him to get his
attention I honestly don't know it's
never been like a real pain point for me
so I've never done the hard sort of
emotional work to figure out why I ended
up doing that stuff to me that the more
interesting questions why did I stop so
when I left for college I said I'm not
gonna be funny anymore I'm going to take
myself seriously as an artist and that
became really important to me and so I
didn't do comedy or anything until after
I graduated college had failed at film
school which is a whole another framing
because there's two ways you could look
at my film school careers being this
tale of you can do anything you set your
mind to or you can look at at it as it
failed and it really changed me and that
is the perspective that I use because I
think it's more powerful but when I got
out and I was sliding towards depression
then I returned to comedy because that
was like okay well I failed as a serious
artist but I'm gonna go back to being
funny which is a whole story because I
got back into it I performed at the
Laugh Factory and do you know who Mitch
Hedberg is yeah okay so imagine this
I've never heard of Mitch Hedberg have
no idea who he is I'm in this really
dark place in my life I think I failed
as a filmmaker I have no idea how to get
back into film none and it's paralyzing
and I'm like okay what do I do what am I
good at comedy great I'm gonna get back
into comedy I start practicing again I
can feel my mind almost speeding up
I see the opportunities for jokes
everywhere this is great I feel good I
feel like my old self like I did back in
high school it's amazing and I go to the
Laugh Factory and it's open mic night
now in an open mic night major comedians
will come but they're trying out new
material so they're they're terrible
even though they're famous and after all
the open mic night or my people most of
the audience is already gone because
they all came to see their friend try
their hand at comedy and then more
famous people come up their materials
terrible so by the time we get to the
last person there's only I'm not joking
like 15 out of 300 people left and so
I'm like I don't think I can do another
one of these but I wanted to learn right
like I've been listening or how they try
material all that and I get up to leave
my friend and I and Mitch Hedberg
manager comes on stations like guys guys
before you go
the
next man coming is the funniest man in
America you are not gonna want to miss
this and I thought you got it with that
kind of build-up you got to give it a
shot right what could it hurt
so we sit back down and this guy had
never heard it before ever in my life
walks out and he is so funny rich that
actually during his bit I'm laughing so
hard I thought to myself can you die
from laughing because I could not catch
my breath it was that funny and I
thought if he keeps going I'm actually
going to die here in the theater and so
at the end of that I thought okay that's
funny that's how good you can get and I
thought to get that good I would have to
dedicate my entire life to it and I'm
not prepared to do that so that became
this moment where I was like okay I
closed the door on that and it's not as
clean as it's gonna sound in the story
but I closed the door on being a comic
and that only left filmmaking and so I
was like how am I gonna get good at this
and so I started researching the brain I
came across brain plasticity and it was
hotly debated in the late 90s is the
brain plastic can you learn as you get
older or is it sort of done at eleven
twelve thirteen and I thought well some
people are taking it seriously that you
can change your brain that you can learn
new things you can push yourself and
people now can't remember that this was
actually credible scientist saying you
can't what it's locked
what you have is what you have there's
no way to change it you're losing brain
cells every day and there's a reason
that you can't learn any language
without an accent it's just it's done
but I chose to believe that the people
who are saying no no no the brain is
plastic until the day you die I choose
to believe that they were right even
though I wasn't sure and that led me
down this path of thinking about cuz I
started teaching filmmaking and I was
like I'm able to make their films better
if the brain is plastic and I can learn
something new and I'm able to make their
films better why can't I make my own
better and so that became the thing that
ended up putting me down the path of
actually developing what we now call the
growth mindset but back then didn't have
a name right and so why then did you not
pursue filmmaking to the hilt with this
newfound you know understanding of blame
path brain plasticity or at least this
belief that you could develop your skill
why didn't that not be the path I did it
was so yeah yeah so what happened was I
was teaching film
and looking for any way to have the time
to write to put together a screenplay
that I could go out and basically pull
an M night Shyamalan where the script is
so good that I know that somebody's
gonna let me direct it so that was the
path that was on I was teaching meet
these two guys very successful
entrepreneurs there were two things I
promised myself when I was a kid one one
day I'm gonna be rich - I'm gonna have
six-pack abs now I legitimately went
through this thing in high school where
I was like I like poetry and I like
filmmaking which am I gonna pursue and
the reason I ended up pursuing film was
you couldn't get rich being a poet so I
was like cool I love film and it was in
the 80s it was just cranking out
millionaires so I was like this is rad
I'm gonna go do that something I love
and it's something that can make me rich
so they come across my life they're
yoked these guys were like bodybuilder
types they had six-pack abs they were
successful entrepreneurs and they were
like look man you're coming to the world
with your hand out if you want to
control your art you're gonna have to
control the resources so stop being a
teacher stop trying to work your way up
come with us be a part of this startup
work your ass off become a true
entrepreneur get a piece of the company
when we sell you'll be rich and you'll
be able to finance your own films I
thought oh my god this is perfect we
thought it would take about 18 months to
build this technology company up and
sell it and of course it ended up taking
15 years took multiple companies a not a
nervous breakdown but a spiritual crisis
and all of that to realize I was never
gonna chase money again because chasing
money the struggle is guaranteed the
success is not so I needed to love what
I was doing that's a whole nother story
but in there I also actually had a
screenplay produced and a movie starring
Michael Madsen who's famous from
Tarantino films and I thought this is
this is my break this is the beginning
and it was atrocious and I was so
heartbroken with how the movie came out
that I was like I have to stay on this
path I have to control the money and so
I buckled down I did it for 15 years
built a billion-dollar company and
exited that with a whole lot of cash and
am now building my own studio so you
finally arrived at this place where you
can get back to storytelling correct
yeah do you still have you have
aspirations of doing
of content well you know like feature
films aggressively so yeah well you
would you just went through the whole
timeline of everything to like back it
up a little bit it's interesting that
you jumped into this startup situation
because I'm not getting from you that
business was a driving force for you as
a kid it was about an art and expression
yes 1,000% I am NOT a born entrepreneur
yeah not in the slightest and I part of
the reason that my philosophies are what
they are is because I have lived them so
when I talk about the you know having a
negative voice it's because I have one
and it is aggressive I want to talk
about anxieties because I had anxiety
when I talk about being able to become
an entrepreneur it's because I had to so
I didn't have the instincts in fact from
an instinct perspective I didn't have
any and I had to learn all of that now I
would say I do have good business
instincts because I've trained them over
time but I certainly didn't have them in
the beginning and in the beginning of my
business career the and this is real and
I really want people to feel what I feel
when I say this the only contributions
that I would make for probably the first
two years of being in business the only
contributions I would make to a
conference call were to say goodbye and
I remember looking forward to that I was
finally gonna get to say something but
because at least I knew enough to keep
my mouth shut when I didn't know and I
didn't understand I didn't want to look
stupid
so I would just be quiet I would listen
and learn I'm very grateful to the guys
that gave me the opportunity they would
let me on the call so I was often in
rooms that I probably would never have
been allowed to be in if I'd been in a
traditional company but because it was a
startup they just kept letting me listen
in on phone calls and stuff so that
ended up being really really
extraordinary for me but yeah I had to
learn to be an entrepreneur so why did
these two yoked dudes want to invite you
in to this startup play like what was it
about you that it that attracted them to
you so they have what words would they
use so they thought that I was bright
they thought that I could write and they
thought we need a copywriter so let's
bring this guy in we're basically going
to get underpriced talent and because as
a teacher you know
much money so they didn't have to fight
very hard to pay me what I was making as
a teacher so they could they moved me
over they said look this is our whole
vision and they were very very
compelling and this is our vision 18
months sell the company come over be a
part of this you're gonna have what you
need to finance your own films so I
thought this is amazing and I remember
asking them guys this all seems too good
to be true everyone I've talked to about
the job offer you guys have made me is
telling me that don't do it like there's
no civility these guys are crazy if it
sounds too good to be true it is too
good to be true and so of course cuz no
one in my family knows startups or
anything like that and I said this isn't
a trick to get me into business is it
because you know I want to be a
filmmaker and they were like laughing
and they're like Tom don't be so
ridiculous like there are easier ways to
just get a traditional employee mm-hmm
and I was like okay yeah that makes
sense and then and in all sincerity I
think what they saw was a kid they
understood this dream they really
thought they could make it happen and
they really didn't think it would take
15 years so while I ended up getting
sucked into business I really don't
think that was I just think they saw
somebody that they could get more out of
than they were gonna be right that's
there and so you had an exit from this
technology play and it's the same dudes
that you started quest with yeah yeah so
I ended up working with him for 14 years
life so what started the technology
company was rapidly turning into an I
don't know what's this is gonna be so at
about six and a half years I went in and
quit I said I can't do this anymore I'm
moving to Greece my wife happens to be
Greek I'm gonna move to Greece because I
speak Greek but I won't say that I'm
truly fluent so I'm gonna go there get
truly fluent cut my expenses to nothing
live some meager existence and right and
I'm gonna come back being fluent in
Greek and having you know a couple
screenplays that'll just be bulletproof
and they were like whoa whoa whoa and I
said here's your coup because by then I
had earned 10% of the company through
sweat equity and I said here's your
equity back if you sell the company
tomorrow for a billion dollars I'm
you're never gonna hear from me I get it
I'm not crossing the finish line I
shouldn't get anything for this and that
was huge for me because I really
believed at that moment I was walking
away forever and I knew no matter what I
would never because they had been sued
by other people who felt in previous
companies and they were always
ah so gross you create opportunity for
people and I was like they created
opportunity for me I'm walking away so I
was like yeah there it is and I'm going
to go do my thing and they said look we
could do this without you but we don't
want to and that's what I needed to hear
to reconnect and to the Brotherhood and
be about something other than the money
and so I said look I've already done the
hard thing which is quit so now let me
tell you who I really am what I'm really
about what drives me and I I thought
that my primary driver was getting
wealthy and I realize now that it's not
and my primary driver is fulfillment and
chasing money does not fulfill me and so
hey I'm living the cliche of money can't
buy happiness so you had that
realization before the money came in oh
yes well yes so on paper I was
technically a multimillionaire but let
me tell you there's a huge difference
between paper money and real life money
so what when I gave back the equity I
was giving back about two million
dollars mmm but it was just paper money
it's not real right so I don't expect
some like oh my god that's so amazing
right it was you know maybe one day
it'll be worth something maybe one but
you didn't go to Greece I did not right
I didn't even make it home and I was
pulling into my driveway when they
called me and said come out to dinner
with us and then that changed the course
of my life because then I could finally
say like look I want to create value in
people's lives I don't just want to sell
them something I didn't use the words
authentic at the time it's a buzzword
now but back then it nobody was saying
it but what I said was I want the
company to reflect our real
personalities who we are what we want to
do in life the things that were
passionate about I wanted to just pour
through an everything that we do and so
we moved away from really boring
security software to something that we
were gonna be passionate about and the
phrase that I used was we need to ask
ourselves what would we do and love
every day even if we're failing because
the struggle has guaranteed the success
is not so for three very different
reasons we end up launching quest
nutrition but it was born out of that
misery it was born out of I'm never
gonna be this unhappy again I want to
feel alive I know about myself I like
community I like connection I like
seeing people being able to help them I
want to add value I don't want to steer
by money look money is important and
don't get me wrong I want to make even
more money in my life but there's a
certain way
I want to make it I want to make it by
creating things that people value
tremendously and they would rather have
them the money I don't do hard sales
tactics it just doesn't make me feel
good so there are ways to generate
tremendous wealth in your life that are
all value add humanity plus and so that
was the driver now part of the reason
that we ended up being so successful is
while that's now and vogue at the time
everyone thought we were crazy we come
out talking about authenticity about
passion about community that there
wasn't social media as a phrase didn't
exist but using today's language we're
gonna do all of the socially all of our
marketing is gonna be social media we
I'm gonna do storytelling I'm gonna go
back to stories I'm gonna tell people
what it means to support this company to
buy this product what does it say about
them who are they who are we and then
we're gonna step forward as people as
individuals we want people to know who
we are and we're gonna put employees
first so its employees first then
customer and when you do that you're
building this like tight ecosystem of
people that you believe in the believe
in you it's just meant it's really
extraordinary and now it's a movement
but we were early just early enough
using social media just early enough
that we just broke and it just went
crazy
yeah what's interesting is that I I
guess I thought oh you you exited the
technology play and then we're sitting
on some cash and then had the idea like
okay well what's next but it wasn't like
that right it was more of a pivot
midstream
for sure so walk me through the pain
moment of of making that decision and
how you come to this realization that
you want to be involved in a more
purposeful fulfilling service-oriented
kind of endeavor I was for the first
three years I I felt so amazing I was on
fire so I leave teaching and I go into
this place where I know nothing but now
I'm thinking about brain plasticity I'm
thinking about learning and now I'm
around guys they believe in that to
their core and they were all like what
do you want to be you could be anything
but you've got a like bust yourself in
half to figure who are these dude it's
like you just stumbled into quite a
partnership a thousand percent
life-changing in a million ways and the
fact that they were so growth minded now
put me when they say you're the average
of the
will you spend the most time with the
five people so now I have my wife
totally growth mindset and I have my two
business partners who at the time were
just my employers but they were totally
growth mindset and they helped me to a
crazy high standard and so they kept
telling me stop thinking like an
employee start thinking like an owner if
you act like an owner and deliver
results will make you an owner but you
have to actually live up to that and
they're like you can have any job in
this company you want but you have to
become the right person for the job I
thought whoa like what if that's real
what if that's not a gimmick and so I
put it to the test and I remember one
day deciding okay cool if this is real
I'm gonna show up everyday acting like
I'm the only person here and that if I
don't do it it's not gonna get done
which means I don't have a job
description anymore there's just [ __ ]
that needs to get done and I'm going to
do said things and that changed
everything it changed our relationship
changed dynamics so for the first three
years it was empowering me I was
learning lessons and even though I was
in a pretty intense sort of almost like
Marshall Rd environment where I was like
you just get kicked in the face and
knocked down and nobody is helping you
back up part of it is they want to see
if you'll get back up and so it was it
was intense to say the least but for me
what I needed I needed to toughen up
it's not what everybody needs but that
was precisely what I needed and I was a
kid that I remember one time getting hit
in the leg with a soccer ball in the
middle of a game and it's cold in
Washington but got hit in the leg and it
left an imprint of the soccer ball and I
just walked off the field because it
hurt and so to me it's like it hurt why
would I keep doing this
and so that was like a pattern in my
life like if it hurt emotionally or
physically I would just quit and so this
was the first time where I was around
these like tough mofos they did not play
around they expected you to rise to
their level they led by example they
were all in busting ass and I just
thought this is rad man this is what I
need I need to go hard
and the harder I went the better I got
and I saw like and I started working out
which this is huge you'll get this more
than anybody so never really worked out
my entire life I'd started probably a
year before I met them working out and I
was like whoa you can actually change
your body goes into this whole brain
plasticity thing and then I met them and
they were yoked so I was like just tell
me what to do and for the first year
they wouldn't they were like you're
never gonna stick
you're never gonna see it wouldn't even
tell you no so I started working out
basically to prove them wrong to be like
no no no I'll stick with this and then
the more I worked out the more they
started giving me advice I chose to
listen to just them and so all the
sudden all the noise of the world of
like do this don't do that like people
giving you conflicting information I
just had one ideology to listen to maybe
it's not the best ideology but once
you're focused you have at least one
thing you'll optimize for that and so it
just changed my life and I ended up
putting on like 60 pounds largely fat
but also muscle and that showed me that
whoa you can transform your body and
that really made me believe in just how
far I could transform my mind yeah and
you grew up like as an overweight kid
right here's the problem so I was a
chubby kid but I did not think of myself
as chubby and I was only chubby by the
standards of the 1980s and early 1990s
which if you saw a picture of me now you
be like you weren't chubby compared to
today I was shredded but back then to
give you an idea so I grew up my family
is morbidly obese by any standard even
back then and I thought okay I'm the
skinny one in a heavyset family and then
I go to college and because I'm working
so hard now which is a whole nother
story working my ass off I lose like 30
35 pounds my freshman Wow so it's just
crucial without thinking without trying
I was just working too much and I'd have
any money so I couldn't afford junk food
so I go home and or no sorry the next
year's at the beginning of my freshman
year I met a girl I knew in high school
and she takes one look at me she's like
oh my god I didn't recognize you I was
used to think of you as the chubby kid
and so at 19 all of a sudden it in like
a sixth sense moment my whole life
played back as me as the fat kid and I
was like how is this possible and so I
realized that like even though I would
suck in my gut so it wouldn't push out
my shirt too much people could tell it
wasn't exactly svelte yeah so it is very
unfair of me to say that like oh I was
obese or anything like that I didn't get
heavy until I was in my mid-20s then I
got heavy mmm and so why the it's it
seems like a strange pivot to go from
security software to nutrition and bars
a you know it's completely unrelated
business and B it's also a crowded
marketplace everyone told us we were
crazy they're like what are you doing
you make money in technology you lose
money in food what are you doing and in
2009 when we first started planning on
launching the company there were 1600
flavors of bars and combinations of
companies on the market system bars 1600
I can't imagine what it's now Oh even
worse and we went to a distributor and
he said I need another protein bar like
I need another hole in that and we
thought whoa okay but there isn't a
single bar in the market that myself and
my partners would eat so we like we know
there's at least a market of three and
our whole thing is steer by what's
metabolically true so we were just like
man you can take your blood sugar and
figure out if you should be eating those
bars or not and they they I mean they
had like thirty and forty grams of sugar
in our competitors bars so we're like
this is crazy they either have no sugar
and tastes terrible or they have all
kinds of sugar and tastes good but your
blood Sugar's gonna spike you might as
well eat a Snickers bar no joke so we
were like we're gonna make the first bar
that tastes like it has sugar but
doesn't now needless to say that was
infinitely harder than we thought it was
going to be but because we had such
aggressive growth mindsets and by this
point even I and I was the new kid on
the block had eight and a half years by
the time we founded that company of just
diehard entrepreneurial experience
so you've got three seasoned
entrepreneurs coming into this company
not knowing anything about it but having
the will to win and so what ended up
happening was I'm sure a thousand people
before us had formulated a bar that
tasted just like ours and had no sugar
and the reason they never went to market
is the second we went in because
equipment has developed in lockstep with
use of high fructose corn syrup as soon
as you take the high fructose corn syrup
out your bar may taste amazing but it
won't mass-produce because all of the
equipment is counting on the existence
of that because of the texture that it
gives it so all of the pressure
tolerances and all that are designed to
have high fructose corn syrup so
everybody else hits that roadblock and
they just start adding high fructose
corn syrup they try to add as little as
possible but they do it to make it run
we said oh I guess we're gonna have to
develop our own equipment and become her
own manufacturers so when every
manufacturer told us you can't make this
bar not profitably any way no way we
said okay well then we'll have to do it
ourselves we bought equipment
learn very quickly that people were
right you can't produce it on standard
equipment but it just so happened that
one of my partners is a literal Iowa
farm boy and could fix anything so he's
looking at the equipment he's like I
know how to cut this apart and put it
back together and it'll work without if
we do that and you're wrong we're now in
real trouble because all of our money
will be tied up in this whereas before
we could have at least resold the
equipment and he does it and it works
and it was just like holy hell what was
it that had to be changed about the
equipment to allow you to produce its
scale without that ingredient we had to
be able to put more pressure on the
product because it ours wasn't like
liquidy like high fructose corn syrup is
ours is more like Kevlar really soft
until you put it under pressure and then
it would get hard so we had to put
enough pressure that it would form the
bar and that it would stick through as
it was cut but not so much pressure that
the bar itself to the end consumer would
be hard so that was a big thing and then
also in traditional manufacturing you
cool it before you cut it but if we did
that our product became too brittle so
there were just all kinds of changing
equipment and reordering things and all
that but yeah so did you have your own
facility manufacturing facility yeah
I was manufacturing so for the first
year I was the only one that was there
full-time other two partners were still
running the tech company and so I'm in a
hairnet everyday lab coats gloves and
making protein bars Wow and what is the
the secret to go I mean it's trying to
think about how to articulate this so
you have this bar but that's still very
different from the ubiquity with that
bar you know has today I mean you can't
go anywhere without seeing it the thing
is everywhere how did you penetrate the
market so completely well that's a very
long road but it starts with social so
we're like all we care about is
community man we just maybe this is a
big business maybe it's not but I'm
gonna go speak to people that I know and
understand that no one understand me so
we're gonna go after other people that
are lifting weights every day like we
were and so we went after bodybuilders
and figure competitors and just said
look this is the first protein bar that
isn't a candy bar in disguise we hit him
up on social we you know it wasn't
called DMing back then but like you
build this relationship on social and
connect with these people from all over
the place well this is a model that's
repeated time on now now it's standard
then it was like what are you doing like
people actually did not understand it so
but because we knew like our marketing
messages that were good people we're not
trying to sell something and we're
living through a time now where the most
powerful marketing message you can have
is to actually be a good person to lead
with value creation to try to give more
value than you get like it's just
powerful marketing stuff but no one was
doing it back then so you want to talk
about cutting through the noise we cut
through the noise like this hey rich
calls quest and he says hey guys look
I'm really trying to get in shape what
should I do
you should eat chicken breast and
broccoli do you guys sell chicken breast
broccoli no we don't then why is that
your answer because it's true and you
should only eat our product and those
times where you're on the run or you
need something that just tastes like a
cookie and you can't have any more
boiled vegetables or whatever and so
people like whoa like these guys aren't
trying to sell hard we would send out a
newsletter and it would just be recipes
that you could make with our product so
never said go buy our product nothing
just like hey here's cool stuff that
people are doing and we developed what
we called mirror marketing so we wanted
to reflect the consumer back so we told
people hey if you put the bar in the
microwave it makes it really soft so
people nuts for that but then they
started telling us oh by the way if you
do this and this and mix it with this
and chop it up you can make ice cream
you can make cookies yeah we're like
whoa so we started saying hey so-and-so
told us you can do this look at this
isn't this amazing
so people like wow that's rad like if I
submit stuff they might like call me out
and hype my stuff and so it just became
them seeing themselves exactly mm-hmm
yeah that's amazing so you go over like
a four five year period you well from
2010 to 2013 you become one of the
fastest growing companies in North
America it's crazy right I'm he must I
had to staff up like crazy ah dude this
is I wish people could see this now
because people think of growth like that
as being like a digital product or
something where it's like what did
Instagram got to a billion dollar
valuation with like eight employees or
something that is not how things went
for us so we were a manufacturing
business so we had to buy equipment
which has like six eight twelve monthly
times we had so imagine you're growing
your
month-over-month and you've got a
project out 12 months think about how
terrifying that is from a capital
perspective because you're only making
the money you're making today but you've
got to spend the money that you're gonna
need to be spending for 12 months routes
absolutely bananas you do a crazy
capital raise no we did literate we had
one mezzanine debt round very small but
it gave us enough that we were able to
get to the point where we could borrow
against accounts receivable so we could
get the line of credit and again Madol
up to my partner who managed all that
stuff which is absolutely a genius with
building those relationships we had a
belief make friends before you need them
so it was like we were very proactive in
that stuff but even just getting the the
square footage that we needed to be
manufacturing out of was pure insanity
and you would move into a space and
think that we're good here for the next
three years and I'm not joking you'd be
out in six months it was so crazy it was
just happening so fast and we had to
staff up the way the way the staff was
crazy it led to one of the most
beautiful periods of my life though
which was we put we needed people so we
put out on the street that we would hire
people even if they had felony
convictions so we had people lined up
around the building just to get an
interview and that was extraordinary and
introduced me to just some beautiful
beautiful humans that completely shaped
my belief system is why I launched
impact theory because when you see
enough lives where it's like these are
extraordinary people who will do nothing
with their life because they don't
believe they can like that yet that
really shade Wow so by 2050 it was
around 2015 that you're at the billion
dollar point but yeah by 2015 we had
already like cashed out a little bit and
had just tremendous financial success
that was is that when you exit it I left
at the end of 2016 okay and when did you
start impact Theory dot next day oh you
did okay so there was a clean break in
between the two for you
well yeah it was transitioning from one
to the next right so most people who
would come into obscene wealth like this
you know would think about buying an
island or you know go going off and
living some crazy life of luxury or
traveling the world for the next five or
ten years essentially doing nothing
and you decide to invest in this new
endeavor seemingly immediately like why
did you make that decision
well that was thankfully a reaction to I
went through the pain of living the
cliche of money can't buy happiness
early so that was the very thing that
gave birth to my true financial success
so walk me through that though so as
most people will never experience what
it's like to come into crazy wealth yeah
it is it is a really funny moment and
funny is the right word it's it's fun
but it's also funny in that when I was
growing up part of the reason I wanted
to get rich was I looked at those people
with admiration and I did not look at
myself with admiration so I thought oh
well if I can get wealthy then I will
look at myself with admiration this
would be amazing and then when I got the
money by then I had changed myself
fundamentally as a person and I had
earned so much self-respect and so much
self-worth that by the time I got the
money I didn't I wasn't looking for
anything from the money other than it is
dog great facilitator it will let you do
extraordinary things but it won't make
you an extraordinary person and won't
make you feel any differently about
yourself and because the money came
literally like that because we had paper
wealth so I was a worth hundreds of
millions of dollars on paper but I just
cannot stress enough that's meaningless
in your real life I was driving you know
at one point a beat-up Ford Focus my
wife and I had to share it had a leaky
exhaust and yet I'm worth at that point
I was worth tens of millions of dollars
but there were employees that were
living far better lives and I was from
the financial standpoint
so that's paper money now bank account
money came in an instant and so it was
about I don't know six years into our
journey and we decided to take a small
investment to diversify so it was a pure
founder liquidity moment and because the
valuation of the company was over a
billion dollars you can imagine even at
a small percentage just the raw number
of dollars is in sanity so all the
sudden I was fantastically wealthy but I
was like it is so in fact this this was
how that day went so everyone I said
earlier you beliefs values identity
habits routines right these are the
things that make people up
and I just have a value system that says
it's not about the money it's about
building something you believe in it's
about serving other people it's about
work ethic it's about showing up and
working and I value myself for that
so on the day that the money hit it hit
it like I know 8:00 a.m. in the morning
or something and my wife were both in
the gym and she's like what are we gonna
do today and I was like what do you mean
I'm going to work and she like couldn't
wrap her head around aha she's like whoa
we're gonna go to the Lamborghini dealer
yeah she's like come on we've got to
like go do something we've got to
celebrate and I'm like there's no
universe in which I don't show up for
work today none under no circumstances
so if you were to ask my employees when
did the money hit the he'll be like I
have no idea they knew that it did hit
but they didn't know what day because I
acted completely the same and the things
I want people to understand is I feel
the same so all of the like things that
I believe about myself to be good
I still believe to be good I earned them
I earned them by doing the hard thing
time and time and time and time again I
know how much I'm willing to serve
people and my family and myself and all
I just know I've done it for years and
years and years so when it came to do I
buy an island and retire or do I double
down it came down to what will make me
love my life the most and the reality is
the thing that would make me love my
life the most because it would still be
fun to just go home be with my wife but
the thing that make me love my life the
most is to do the things that are
fulfilling and I think fulfillment has a
very specific universal formula and that
formula is work your ass off to get very
good at something that you care deeply
about that allows you to serve not only
yourself but other people that's it you
got to have all of it technique
literally yes perhaps it is literally
technique yeah and people they don't
like what that is for people that don't
know so it's this ancient Greek notion
of fulfillment basically and the fact
that it's coming from that word techne
like to get good at something and
something that's hard so the way that I
explain it to people is people think of
like doing some of that going and
ladling soup at a soup kitchen which may
be the right place to start but
ultimately you're gonna realize anyone
can do this and so I haven't earned
something special that allows me to
serve myself in humanity so it's part of
it
is working your ass off to get a set of
skills have real value and my whole
thing here's this may be the biggest
problem we face as a society people
don't remember that skills have utility
they let you do something you don't
learn to build a house to impress your
parents you learn to build a house so
people can live in the house you build
and once people understand that like
holy [ __ ] you're building this house so
somebody can live in it build a home in
it have a family be sheltered from
storms like [ __ ] it's a real thing man
and so all of that effort and energy
went into I have the chills right now is
so you can create that moment for
yourself for other people it is it is
something so much more than going to
architecture school which maybe you went
to because your parents wanted that and
they they were architects and so you do
that thing for that and you forget the
whole reason you became an architect was
to build houses and so once people
realize oh I'm putting all of this time
and energy to build these things because
they let me do something what do I want
to do what do I want to give what do I
want to create when you look at skills
from that perspective it is like it is
being a superhero it is being a
superhero you're going to collect these
abilities these abilities actually let
you do something the fact that Superman
can fly allows him to save people allows
him to do things other people can't do
we all have this opportunity to become
capable of the extraordinary to be able
to do things other people can't do and
that feels so good
the thing is though most the thing
that's unique about you is that you were
able to come to this realization and
develop a level of maturity and
self-awareness without having to go to
the you know play it out at the
Lamborghini dealership right because
most people who would come into that
kind of wealth would go and have that
experience for a period of time only to
discover you know what you just
expressed but on the other side of it so
why were you able to do that why were
you able to avoid that experience and
circumvent it they say a fool never
learns a smart man learns from his
mistakes and a wise man learns from the
mistakes of others far too often I've
been a fool
and have repeated mistakes over and over
and over and but I really do try to be
smart I'm not usually as wise as I would
like to be and just find that I I
learned things the hard way but I really
do learn them so pain for me is a
tremendous instructor maybe because I
hate it so much and just want to move
away from it but thankfully I don't run
from it I figure out what I did that
made me feel that pain whether it's what
I value myself for or whether it's just
hey bad skill set you need to address it
and then actually addressing it so in
the time where I was chasing money and I
like I said the first three years gave
to me and then the next three years
chipped away at my my ability to enjoy
my life so it's actually in the founding
of quests that you learned that lesson
it was in the it was in building
awareness technologies so building
awareness technologies I did not enjoy
the process and so at the end of that I
had spent about three and a half years
being profoundly unhappy profoundly
where it's like it was hurting my
marriage my wife would want to talk
about work and I wouldn't want to talk
about it
I would get this like sense of dread as
I approached the office it was just
gnarly man and it was in that period
that I developed really crushing anxiety
because AI was always in over my head
because I didn't know anything about
business and it was just really hard to
learn I was in a very intense
environment where it's just like you'd
hear things like only an idiot would do
that like all day every day I feel like
oh my god this is exhausting and so you
put that all together and I'm doing all
of that for a product I don't believe in
I'm not building community I'm not
connected to people like community all
that's of it none of it existed so I was
just like I am so unhappy and so talking
to my wife I was like anything would be
better than this and somebody wrote an
article unfortunately only read the
headline but I know the feeling that it
resonated and it was the joy of quitting
and there's that moment when you first
quit and it's like the lift the burden
lifted off you is so profound because
that that particular frame of reference
is just in an instant that's gone and
that's amazing and that's what I was
thinking about when I went in and quit I
was like I just need the change of
circumstance badly and so my solution
was going to be to go do the only thing
that ever made me feel awesome and that
is creating film so and I didn't have
the finances to make my
actual films but I could write them
which is essentially just your time and
I remember there was a time before I
quit where I had directed a feature film
and I direct this feature film over a
few weekends and then I edited myself
nights and weekends and there was a time
I was if I could finish it before
Christmas I'd be able to play it for my
family because it was never gonna go
theatrical and I was so excited to do
that that I was sleeping between 45
minutes in two hours a night without
setting an alarm for like 10 days and I
thought this is inhuman how is it
possible I'm waking up with this little
sleep and it was because I was so
excited I wanted to like get this film
done and show it to everybody and the
actual act of cutting it together which
for anybody who messes with film here
off camera they know it is so fun when
you see it like come together and you're
creating this moment you feel something
and you give yourself the chills it's
like that for me makes me feel alive I
was like I want to feel like that all
the time so that was all I knew I was no
smarter than that
I just knew feeling dead inside hating
my life hating my job was so miserable
I'd rather be poor doing something that
I loved then rich doing something that I
hated and so now I knew that about
myself then building quest really taught
me about technique fulfillment all the
things that mattered meeting these
former drug dealers and gangbangers and
like really connecting with them as a
human in Washington blossom gave me
something that I never could have
predicted and then I haven't talked
about I don't know if I've ever
mentioned this to you I Big Brother 4 18
half years oh wow and that ended up
planting is he it didn't unfortunate was
too young this is one of those moments
where I was definitely not being wise
and I was probably being a fool I was
being changed by this relationship but I
didn't really understand I was too young
so I started Big Brother when I was 18
and I he was eight and I stayed with him
until he was 16 it was a crazy
experience
he was very had massive developmental
problems and was just a great kid man he
was just a great kid and it started as
an extra-credit assignment and
it was only supposed to be eight weeks
and at the six week mark they tell you
to warn them I warned him that I was
only coming for two more weeks and he
went nuclear what's going on and I'm
like is this because I said I'm only
coming for two more weeks and he says
yes and I'm like all right look as long
as I live in Los Angeles I will help you
with your homework but you have to stop
freaking out all the time because he was
really problematic I was like you have
to do your homework when were together
you have to do your homework is it a
deal
he says yes and that turns into the
eight and a half year relationship and
he end up finding out that he was being
beaten by his adoptive mother and he
gets taken out of the home I get made
the Guardian I help him into foster care
he is really really crazy but I was too
young and stupid to really know what to
do with that or what to make of it and
unfortunately I will say I probably
didn't I gave him somebody he knew loved
him but I didn't change his life and
that makes me sad mmm do you know what
he's doing now I touched base them like
through somebody else once briefly about
four years ago and I've tried to get in
touch with him again but he didn't have
a phone and so yeah but it's the point
of that story that that experience
informed how you would then create bonds
with these ex felons that came to work
that was part of it it what that the
reason that I was so open to hiring ex
convicts was one I just have a belief
that it doesn't matter what you've done
it only matters who you want to be and
the price you're willing to pay to
become that person so it's like yeah
yeah we all have pasts we've all either
done stupid things or had stupid things
happen to us and so being stuck there
doesn't make any sense
you get to choose what you do tomorrow
so that just being in my ethos and then
rashon who was the little kid he was a
beautiful human and everybody thought he
was a piece of [ __ ] and I just thought
that sucks because he has misbehaved
that is for sure but he's a beautiful
human and they're just too overwhelmed
to have the time to stop and see the
person and so that sort of made me fall
in love with him and I just thought this
kid is so like amazing and I thought of
him like my own little brother and I was
just like dude I love this kid I won't
get things for him and so it just showed
me that like there
or there's a whole swath of humanity
that people just sort of brush aside and
through him they spoke to me and so that
made me want to create this opportunity
for other people that I knew were in
similar situations that it had rough
upbringing x' of the most extraordinary
kind and i knew some percentage of them
not all but some percentage of them are
going to be the most beautiful kind
loving compassionate human beings ever
who are capable of these amazing things
but somebody has to introduce the
mindset to them yeah and so that became
my mission yeah it's interesting because
the more predictable route for you once
you exited quest would be to get an
office in Hollywood hang a shingle out
higher development exec and start
reading scripts and getting involved as
a producer right I mean nobody would
have batted an eye lots of people do
that that's kind of the tried-and-true
route for the the newly-minted rich guy
who wants to get into film yeah that is
for sure and I think think about that or
no no I'm not not even momentarily to me
it was it was very clear that I want to
stay and control the project and that if
you so whenever you're doing something
ask who's living my idealized life and
looking at that it was very clear the
person living my idealized life in terms
of their ability to impact was Walt
Disney and so okay I'm like I'm looking
at this guy and I'm like what made him
so different why is the Walt Disney
Company still the most powerful studio
and it became very clear to me that they
had done something that had never been
replicated and that I was the right
person to replicate it again and that
was they told one story from a thousand
different angles and because of that the
brand began became to mean something and
keep in mind the world's changed so much
social media all that so that's in the
back of my mind as well I've I've
already had luck at this social thing
people are resonating with my message
I'm able to touch people it's real what
I'm putting out there if you follow the
advice it will change your life for the
better would you universally I believe
that so I thought okay well I can have
the discipline to only tell one kind of
story so that the brand itself begins to
mean something so that the ultimate
marketing vehicle becomes to just
leverage the brand to say this is an
impact Theory thing and once you know oh
wow this is an impact Theory thing then
it's like you
don't have to do all the legwork and the
way I explain it to people is if I say
I'm gonna go see a paramount movie or
Warner Brothers movie you don't know
anything about it but if I say I'm gonna
go see a Disney movie
you already know something so I have one
belief and that is a the 25 point belief
system that's it like that encompasses
my whole ethos so I want to tell stories
that empower people period simple-ass so
my thing is if Disney can create the
most magical place on earth could we
create the most empowering place on
earth I don't mean physically like a
Disneyland but by telling stories both
nonfiction through social media and
fiction through comic books movies TV
shows could I create an ethos that was
as clear and easy to recognize as Walt
Disney's magic that was about
empowerment and so that's we're about so
there will be some element of we're
reading scripts and being producers and
attaching things and just getting things
produced but the the real thing is if
Disney were founded today I think
there'd be a huge social component and
there there's it's not a mistake that
Walt Disney at one point was considered
the most famous man in the world and the
US government literally would send them
on goodwill missions to other countries
so there's just something about when you
have an ethos that people can believe in
when there's a face to the company and
it's not just a corporation there's
someone to believe in there's someone to
get value from even if you're not
consuming their product like there's
just people gravitate towards that now
in the era of social media and I have
the same feeling I have now that I had a
quest which was it's the right message
at the right time and so given where
everything is going so we started two
years ago the word impact now is like
everywhere and it's because that was we
could see like emotionally because
that's where I was I wanted to make
impact and I could see that that's where
the world is going like people just want
to make impact and Millennials feel that
but gen Z is obsessed by it and so I
think that there's just I'm on a
collision course right now to make
content that Gen Z is gonna be changed
by and so that that is really what I'm
about is is creating the content that is
going to define culture and what is the
long-term vision is Disney I mean
that's the easiest way to sum it up the
reality is it will take roughly 75 years
to mimic a Disney I get that in terms
today theme park I don't think so
and this is where it gets into any 75
year time horizon is absolutely
laughable
so I used Disney as a shorthand things
will change so much technologically in
the next 75 years we may be uploading
our consciousness like I get it it's
gonna be so different it is quite
literally impossible to predict where
we're going so I don't even bother
trying I just so people understand the
sort of gravitas of what we're trying to
build is to say we're building the next
Disney so then you understand that I'm
gonna be in comic books I'm gonna be in
movies I'm gonna be in TV show I'm gonna
be in distribution we're gonna be in
video games we're gonna be in VR we're
just not going to do it all at once
we're gonna start with an area of core
competency right now our area of core
competency is the social stuff we make
an awesome show I'll vouch for that
beyond that we're completely untested
we've put out a comic book we're getting
the traction key thing and I think that
it's amazing and that's why that we give
it away because I just want people to
read it I want people to see that the
quality will speak for itself but we did
get picked up we are gonna be in stores
so starting in March of 2019 we'll be in
your local comic book shop you can also
order it online but that I think is
gonna show people that we can really
tell a story at the absolute highest
level we're already working to get that
translated into film and television so
goal in 2019 is to get that place at a
studio and being actively developed for
production so I'm super excited about
that with two other projects that are
being developed but that just helps
people understand like the the grand
vision of where we want to be yeah
that's a big vision I mean it's an
audacious vision like where does this
audacity come from man
so everybody lean in if you're listening
to this this is one of those things that
audacity is is nothing don't don't worry
about being audacious the reason people
fear being audacious is they don't want
to be me ten years from now when this
all fails right they're thinking oh man
what if this doesn't work this guy's
gonna look like an [ __ ]
and it's like yeah maybe other people
will think that I'm a total dumbass it
doesn't matter and why doesn't it matter
because of techne because if I know how
to build a house I can build a house so
my thing is I'm not trying to posture or
be cool I'm telling you I have a set of
[ __ ] skills that set of skills lets
me do things
I'm just interested in doing those
things so whether or not I hit my
timelines does not matter I'm in the
skill acquisition game skills let you do
things I'm in the game of doing the
things my skills allow me to do so I
want to impact people's lives maybe I'm
not able to pull it off at a film level
I'll find another way or maybe it takes
me a lot longer to pull it off okay fine
as long as I love what I'm doing even
when I'm failing there's nothing to lose
no because you know on this idea of
technique along the way you are
fulfilled with every step on the journey
right every time you upload a new you
know conversation a new episode of your
show it's a it's a it's a cool feeling
to be able to put that out there and
know that it is quote-unquote you know
impacting people and it is it is and
that's the thing you know this like you
you say something into a microphone like
right now the the feeling that I have
well I know people are listening the
feeling I have is it's just us in this
room but one day somebody's gonna come
up to you or me and say I heard that
podcast you guys did and it really
touched me and it changed me in this way
that's all I need so I'm not I'm not
afraid to be audacious cuz I know that
you're never going to exceed what you're
aiming at so you're only your hope is to
hit some percentage of what you're
aiming at so I might as well dream
massive and one it excites me and then
two I'm not afraid of the failure so
once you have that like oh it's exciting
for me to dream big and I'm hyper
conscious of you break it down in small
pieces like I'm gonna I'm not worried
about building theme parks and all that
stuff right now what I'm doing right now
today is make a good comic put out a
good interview show that's it that's
what my life consists of stay in
business be profitable like those are
the things that I think about so I keep
my you know my goals my immediate term
goals very manageable but I make sure
that they're feeding naturally into the
grand vision but I don't get scared or
lost and thinking oh my god I have to do
all that nope right now today I need to
read a script I need to make sure it's
okay I need to authorize it to be drawn
that's it that's today and as long as
you're able to focus on that and get
good at that and then just always push
yourself to make your skillset better
and better and better as long as it's
leading towards that thing and you have
clarity on where you're trying to go so
they make sure the skills you're
acquiring will actually lead you there
you'd be fine yeah as you've all know a
Harare famous
says clarity is power indeed it is you
you have you know a very distinctive
profound degree of clarity about what
you're doing and that drives this engine
in large part and you also have very set
kind of rules about how you regulate
your time and live your life and these
principles that you've you know divined
about what drives success etc so I'm
curious how or if the guests that you
have had on your show have challenged
that worldview how have you grown or
changed as a result of doing the show
that you do yeah I mean that that is one
of the greatest gifts that doing a show
like this can do I think you may be the
one that said this like it gives you a
chance to meet people that would
otherwise not give you the time of day
and I'm just like sure so true like
people they just need that little excuse
for like okay at very limited time why
am i coming I don't know you so you know
what I mean like why am I making it so
once you have like oh I can help you
reach an audience get your message out
there give a thoughtful interview then
it's like okay that brought us together
now we may have real chemistry like I'll
speak from my side I have real chemistry
with you so you asked me to come out
here I was like [ __ ] yes I was so
excited to do it and hopefully that this
will be one of many times we get to
spend time together whether it's for
sure on record or not so it's like that
is super fun now because I'm a learner
because that's my identity and because I
really believe whatever skillset you
have today it's already taking you as
far as it's going to take you so unless
this is where you want to be for the
rest of your life you've got to be open
to change you've got a hunger for it so
hey I don't fear change I actually enjoy
change because change has been the thing
that's allowed me to improve my life
consistently and so I'm always looking
for ways in which I'm wrong because I
don't value myself for being right and
once people understand that that for me
it wasn't in the beginning I was just
telling myself to do that it wasn't at a
limbic level now I've been telling
myself to value myself only for my
willingness to admit when I'm wrong and
to learn that at a limbic level it's
true so when somebody tells me I'm wrong
I have this rush of like oh my god this
is amazing because if they're right and
I really am wrong and they're making me
aware of this I'm gonna get more
powerful
so and that goes back to my real belief
in skills having utility so it's like
the ego doesn't have utility yeah maybe
some but it's not when misplaced and and
built around the wrong things can be
super dangerous but because my ego is
actually built around my willingness to
stare at my inadequacies when somebody
tells me that oh you're doing this bad
wrong or whatever I don't spend time it
does still sting I think that's just
natural so it'll be like oh that sucks
but or a reminder that this is going to
give me something powerful and so I use
it sort of as mental jujitsu and then I
open myself up and I learned so what was
Pacific so David Goggin so like I said
the thing I've struggled with in my life
is emotional weakness so being around
people that are very very tough inspires
me to rise to that challenge so really
understanding his notion of like what it
took him to break the world record for
pull-ups and how many times he had to
fail to go through it what he had to do
to his mind to calais his mind the whole
notion of like getting so tough things
get easier over time because just like
you'll callus your hands your collar
mind that's been tremendously impactful
give you as an example like everything
that people know you for comes after
this extraordinary battle with
alcoholism which is like so red like
you're so much more interesting to me
because you went through that so you did
they're like sage like quality which by
the way you feel when you're near you
and I know a lot of your guests probably
never going to actually be in your vibe
and like it's rad and there's it's so
cool because it was born of somebody who
had to go through like they went through
the hero's journey and they've come back
to teach right and so that makes that
really profound so when I think about
okay really having to go through
something and wanting to be wise because
I haven't had to go through that
particular thing I can draw on your
wisdom of having the tenacity to rebuild
to not be afraid to rebuild to not be
afraid to make amends to look at what
you did and maybe most importantly to
reach back to help others and that
becomes a thing that really solidifies
people in their journey so it's like all
of that stuff and just like what you've
done physically man it is crazy to me
ahold you're like it seems impossible
well I appreciate that thank you but
what I what I what I think is
interesting about that is in and we
talked about this when I was on your
show that for me pain has always been a
great teacher
it's it's what reminds me of the
mistakes that I've made it's the thing
that gets me to wake up and actually
modify my behavior and I always couch
out by saying that you know you don't
have to be in pain to change the
opportunity to change is always within
your grasp but it is the rare individual
who can grab onto that without having to
suffer some kind of consequence that
drives that decision change right and I
look at you and I see somebody who whose
trajectory skyward is not as linear as
perhaps an Internet narrative might
couch.you you've had your ups and your
downs and you've battled with you know
everything from self-confidence to
depression and all kinds of things in
there but you haven't had like some big
bottom reckoning moment and I think it's
that commitment to being a learner
that's allowed you to short-circuit that
and grab onto these lifelines as you see
yourself moving in perhaps a negative
trajectory to course-correct before
having to pay that cost you know and
that has you know created this kind of
accelerated trajectory to bring you to
where you are yeah it's funny I was
thinking about this today people don't
have enough rules in their life for
themselves so for instance I get out of
bed in ten minutes less doesn't matter
and I don't want to that's why I have to
rule because I went callous your mind
literally I went through a period where
I would lay in bed for three to four
hours a wash and shame and my inability
to get out of bed and it just
embarrassed me and so I felt badly about
myself so I wanted to make a change so I
knew that I needed a bright line so
bright line ten minutes or less you get
out of bed as soon as you realize you're
awake that's it so and the rule is more
specific it's like I have to have had at
least five hours of sleep but once you
put the rule in place then you just live
by and that's how you earn credibility
like right now I don't feel the way
telling you that that I want to feel
this is a good moment he's on my team
I'm pointing him this is a good moment
so I'm saying this and I don't feel good
about saying it why because today I
don't know what happened I got out of
bed in 11 minutes and I was so literally
timet oh yeah waking up to actually
physically getting out of the bed rekt
my feet must be on the floor and I'm
unless you're channeling up before
six over into the 11th minute and today
I don't know what happened I I was I was
aware of the time I knew I needed to get
up and for whatever reason one of the
minutes just went faster than I thought
when I look back I was like damn it
and so I'm surprised you had made it
here today then right so now this comes
into like knowing how to handle
something like that like if you totally
fall apart because you don't live up 20
rules you're violating another one of my
rules which is don't do anything that
doesn't move you towards your goals so
it's like yes I've I it is a part of my
identity to confess this so because I'm
talking about it I want to say it now to
an audience it's the only thing that
will allow me to reset and be able to
feel good about it against because I
don't lie when I miss it I own it well
look if your biggest problem is it took
you 11 minutes to get right yes very
truly but my thing is people have the
rules and so I have other rules for
instance I wear a size 32 pad there's
just that's it and so no matter what
your waist is no no I won't let my waist
get out of line with that so I used the
pants as a way to guide now I would go
down if I got so lean that I was you
know 31 that's not a problem
but I'm not gonna allow myself to go up
and it's super tempting like especially
around Christmas I don't try to hold ABS
through the winter so during Christmas
like right now I do not have abs so and
I'm totally fine with that I switch a
different part of my mentality I during
the holidays my wife and I definitely
celebrate with food and it's amazing and
I love it the most so but if that
celebration took me up to like 32 s
don't fit anymore I gotta cut back
because I have a rule so it's like
that's how I keep myself in a lane I
keep myself from getting into trouble I
know the things that I accept for myself
when I don't accept myself and it's all
like stated it's very clear so is
somebody who is in this world of self
empowerment and and you know trying to
address this poverty of mindset to use
your phraseology what are the challenges
that you have like where where is it
where are your blind spots if we're in
this zone of vulnerability and
confession like what do you still need
to work on um I think that like really
doing things that scare me is something
I believe in and don't want to do so for
instance
I got hired to speak at a freediving
conference now I told my team that I
would do anything within my code of
ethics to help build the company so when
I got the offer to do the free diving
and he wanted me to free dive rich when
I say my greatest fear in this world is
open water I don't fear anything I can
help me with that that's interesting and
maybe you're the exact person to help me
with it but I that is a gripping fear
for me and so when the offer came in I
said yes
I have to do it and I didn't want to do
it and I was [ __ ] dreading it and the
guy ended up not getting enough people
to sign up for it and I was happy about
that all right and so he cancelled it
and I was so ecstatic and I was like
yeah this is my problem I was glad I got
cancelled
I should be traumatized because it was
no here's what you should do here's what
gave David Goggins never tell you what
you should do is still go to whatever
that location is and get a free driving
instructor and follow through on that
correct and I'm not going to do and that
but this is this is a question you ask
right so I don't value that in myself
that that I think what you just said
would be the best thing for me in terms
of continuing to earn credibility with
myself and I have no intention of doing
it right and I excused it away because
it doesn't lead me towards my bigger
goal of building the company it would be
time away that I'm not getting revenue
that I can give back to the company so
it's like I can they are excuses though
the reality is I'm not doing that
because I'm scared and I don't want to
have to face up here so I have fears
that I allowed to stay in my life that I
don't respect that about myself mm-hmm I
want to talk about your marriage a
little bit yeah you have an amazing
relationship with your wife and I'm
curious as to how you make it work as
life partners and as business partners
because this is something that's
personally you know interesting to me as
somebody who does the same so part of it
is that we're building the same company
because it did not work like that when I
hated my job she wasn't working at all
she was a stay-at-home wife at the time
and I'm working I hate my job I don't
want to come home and talk about it I'm
working around the clock
around the clock and so I just wasn't
spending time with her so it was a
nightmare and so finally at 6:00 nap
years she pulls me aside and says this
is now damaging our marriage now going
back to like your rules and all that it
my highest value is my marriage that's
the thing I value over the wealth over
ambition everything so if ever I was
doing something that's damaging my
marriage I'm gonna correct course and so
that was part of why I went in and quit
and I started taking time off so you got
married young right I did I did
yeah I got married at 26 and so
realizing that okay I'm now damaging the
marriage and that the marriage is my
highest priority then it's very clear I
need to change something so one that I
have that in the right order in my life
so that when my wife says hey you need
to make a change I actually make it and
I'm not conflicted about it's very easy
then my wife is very good at giving me
all the rope in the world to be
ambitious to pursue those things that
matter to me so much but that she speaks
up when it gets to the point where she
is actually having a hard time now and
she is very good at that on two levels
one not saying it too soon and to
actually protecting the marriage because
I'm bad at that so I get so focused on
what I'm doing and I'm so in love with
trying to solve that puzzle and push it
forward and all that that I would push
things too far for sure and so it's an
area where I always tell people though
the one group that I think there is a
tool that is underutilized by this
community and that is an erect six and I
totally get it it is truly a battle
you're fighting for your life I'm not
making light of this at all
I just know about myself that that the
intoxication of the willpower to not eat
is something I feel very strongly it's
how I ended up losing we ended up losing
60 pounds and eating really lean and the
way that I did it was essentially by
starving myself over extraordinarily
long periods of time and I felt so good
about myself and being able to do it I
thought ah this is how people get
themselves in trouble there's actually a
positive side to this and the sense of
control and power and all that is very
self affirming and I thought okay well
if I know that about myself and
know that I have anorexic tendencies
then I'm just gonna tell my wife you're
in complete control of this the second
you tell me that I'm acting in any way
shape or form in a way that's edging up
towards illness I will stop not because
I want to but because I trust you and
I'm empowering you with something I
don't think I can trust myself on and so
she did then so when I got to that point
she said okay it's now you're starting
to worry me I think they were edging up
on it and I changed instantly not
because I had reached my goals or
because I thought she was right because
in a moment of emotional sobriety I
empowered her to know that I can't trust
myself so getting into that space where
you go I know this is an area that I
have a blind spot I'm not the right
person to make this decision even though
it's actually about myself I'm going to
empower somebody that I'd love and trust
and then I'm actually going to follow
through with that and so that that's a
tool that serves our marriage very well
I know I can trust her to be the
guardian of the relationship in terms of
that are we spending enough time on it
and then it's you know just constantly
looking for ways to better communicate
defining terms there's a whole host of
very specific tools that we use and then
we both have growth mindset so we want
to get better mm-hmm
yeah but you're on the same mission I
think is that's my fundamental aspect of
that and you know people ask me all the
time like how do you work with your wife
how do you make it work and it's a gift
you know it's amazing to have a
collaborative partner that's also your
life partner it's also fraught with
minefields you know you have to be more
consciously aware of how you're
navigating your relationship and also
bifurcating the professional aspect of
what you're doing from the personal
because as you know what you do now
doesn't feel like work even though it is
work and it's very easy without erecting
healthy boundaries and being consciously
mindful of the relationship that all the
conversations can suddenly become about
what you're doing the the projects that
you're working on and the you know the
professional aspect of what you're doing
and you have to really carve out that
time to put that aside and focus on the
relationship itself so true yeah but she
gives you that hard feedback she
she's very good about that she is
equally excited about her own growth as
an entrepreneur so it is very exciting
for us but like you said we are very
careful to carve out the time to just be
husband and wife to play to do things
that are fun to make sure that we're
having sex that that's huge and I think
that oftentimes people let bed death
creep into their life and and keeping
that passion and that physical
connection has been a huge win for us
and is something that look it doesn't
take a lot of effort to want to do that
but to make sure that we're cognizant of
that that we have it's not something
that we state but we're terrified of
becoming roommates and so we're very
conscious to keep that physical spark
the passion very much alive exciting not
routine so that that served us well yeah
yeah I like to think of kind of what
imperils humanity right now can be
boiled down to well many things but
essentially a crisis of consciousness so
many people are living their lives
reactively and I don't mean to be
flippant about that you know life is
hard and people are just trying to you
know earn a living and put food on the
table and get through the day in your
experience with all the you know
business experience that you've had the
books you've read the people that you've
spent time with what do you think is the
biggest impediment to people waking up
out of this matrix-like existence that's
so easy for us to fall prey to so I've
had a realization recently that I'm not
an all lanes driver there are certain
things I've spent so much time thinking
about that I'm very good at answering
questions and there are certain things
that I'm not so I'll give you an answer
that question from my very specific lens
which is all about the person and so I
think that if the things in the world
that scare me the divisive nough scares
me and when I think about what is the
individuals creation of that divisive
is one a desire to belong to a group
intensely a fear of being ridiculed or
emotionally ostracized and once we know
that we have this like sucking need to
belong to be respected to be liked you
can really begin to decide what are the
things that you want to be liked for
respected for and when those are things
that you respect yourself for then all
of a sudden it becomes very easy to do
two things to build something that is
born of connection community kindness
not that you're not self selfish I'm
very selfish it just so happens that the
more selfish I am the more I like to
connect and help other people I am very
much doing it for me
but it manifests in a way that is
humanity neutral worst case and I think
humanity plus ultimately so that that
starts with me having a growth mindset
so that you you want to see how you're
wrong that you can have these really
ferocious ideas but hold them loosely
because the moment that your identity is
wrapped up in your ideas you are in real
trouble man your identity should be
wrapped up in your outcome what outcome
do you want and are you actually getting
that outcome and then as long as you're
not a sociopath with an ugly outcome
like people that get into identity
politics and things like that I'm gonna
give them the benefit of the doubt and
say no for real the the world they
imagine is a beautiful world for the
people that they love and care about
okay fair enough
so I'll just give them that they're
trying to do something positive but when
you look at the outcome in terms of how
it affects everyone it starts to break
down pretty fast like that's where it
really starts to worry me so that to me
says that your identity is based on
something that isn't necessarily anti
fragile it's probably based on something
pretty fragile so to use in the seem to
Lebs term something that is fragile
that's easy to understand something that
is anti fragile isn't something that's
strong or resilient those are still
defined by their breaking point it's
just that their breaking point is far
away but ultimately even something
that's strong it's strong because you
think wow it can take a lot before it
breaks something that's anti fragile on
the other hand actually grows stronger
the more that it's attacked so and that
doesn't mean you entrench in a position
that clearly everybody is saying like
this is crazy
the only anti fragile position
I can think of is to be that of the
learner that is truly anti fragile so
for instance if you come at me and say
that I'm stupid
be like amazing in what way and the
reason that I say amazing is because I I
know that skills make me more powerful
so you've just said that I have a blind
spot which means that I'm less powerful
than I could be and I'll define powers I
think it weird some people out to me
powerful just means you can close your
eyes imagine a world a better world than
the one that we have today
you can then open your eyes and actually
create that world so that's the kind of
power that I'm trying to amass in my
life the ability to impact people at
scale in a positive way so if you're
telling me that I'm less powerful than I
could be amazing I want to know in what
way because once I'm aware of it then I
can address it cuz I know about myself
that I'm willing to accept that I'm
inadequate because I know that it's a
temporary state I'm not good at it yet
if I decide that it really does match
with my goals and what I want to do I
can get good at it so it's not ego
damaging for you to tell me that I've
you know I'm not doing something in a
way that I could be could be better cool
tell me how when people don't want to
hear that it's like oh it's they're in a
very brittle place they're being backed
into a corner and people lash out and
they're backed into a corner so at an
individual level I would say to
everybody if you feel that your blood
boiling when somebody challenges you if
you feel like a caged animal or like
you're being backed into a corner I
promise you 100% it is not the truth of
the world it is that you have a fragile
something in fragile ego a fragile
belief system something in there can
break and because it can break you're
trying to protect it and the more you
try to protect it the more hardened and
potentially violent vicious cruel
whatever that you may become so when it
isn't that and you're not afraid of that
thing breaking because you want to take
information in you want to assess it
doesn't mean you're going to agree you
may take that criticism ago I actually
don't think that's accurate but I'm
really grateful that you gave me that
piece of information and look intention
matters you can tell when someone's just
trying to be a dick so it's like you've
got to be cognizant enough of that but
when you get to that point where you're
you're leading with everything is my
fault
including the way this person's coming
at me I've done something to make them
want to come at me too hard or whatever
so at the individual level I think that
that ant
the fragility versus antifragility is is
where everyone should start well to be
anti fragile you have to feel safe right
so somebody's coming at you and they
have a criticism or a critique and you
feel yourself were coiling or having
some kind of fear response chances are
that there's some truth to it because if
somebody lodges some completely
outlandish accusation at you you can
laugh it off right so there's a kernel
of reality there that you're being
forced to confront and on some level
that challenges you know your membership
in your tribe somehow you feel unsafe in
being open to looking at that right so
you have to feel secure in your self
esteem or in your position in life on
some level in order to receive that in
an objective way and your self esteem
has to be built on something that they
can't attack that's the problem so if
your self-esteem is I'm a good tribe a
then this as soon as I say well tribe a
sucks like you're in real trouble
because your whole esteem is built
around your identity to that group all
the things that make you good are based
on that so for instance in gang culture
there's this notion of putting work in
on the street and could be selling drugs
could be murder could be whatever so if
I now come and say well your gang sucks
there's no way you're gonna take that so
you may have killed for that gang or
done you know things that put you a
tremendous risk or you know you've been
defending your brothers this whole time
so you cannot take on board that that
group isn't worthy right just amazing so
it becomes this real emotional conflict
so my thing is the the going back to
what is anti fragile and you want to
talk about something I'm open-minded to
being wrong about I just keep coming
back to being the learner right so your
identity isn't group a politic this
politic that tribe this tribe that it is
I'm a learner first and foremost I'm
somebody that wants to bring value to
myself into the world
first and foremost so it's like once you
get to that then as people are
assaulting you chances of them
triggering a self-esteem like in like if
somebody wanted to hurt my self-esteem
they would need to call me out on
are you really spending time learning or
have you really improved I didn't give
the same that you were two years ago
like whoa like if I really like you said
felt that that might be true then I
would really that would call some [ __ ]
into question for me because that's my
identity right so if somebody came to
you and said actually you're not a
learner yeah and so that's one of those
for me where my belief is now that's so
absurdist that I would brush it off but
if they were able to like compel me to
see it the funny thing is being a
learner than kicks in again and I'm like
[ __ ] if they're really right then here's
my chance to finally actually be a
learner but so that's why I think that
one's anti fragile but that's where it's
like you can get yourself into trouble
if they're hitting on the very thing
that your identity and self-esteem are
tied to right well these things can be
at odds with each other if that ethos of
being a learner starts to conflict with
your identity within a certain tribe
right so which is going to supersede the
other and people have to make those
decisions that's like I am ultra
ambitious and I told my wife the only
thing you can never ask me to give up
his ambition and at the same time my
marriage is my highest priority it's my
highest value so I'm constantly
balancing the is she asked me to give up
my ambition or she just reminding me
that we've hit a moment where I need to
put it first and I need to stop working
for a day or two days whatever and
really just give her my undivided
attention and as long as it doesn't feel
like she's actually asking me to get rid
of my ambition then it's like yeah of
course because that that is what I want
for myself it is the thing that's
brought me the most value in my life is
my marriage for sure
what does that ambition come from that I
don't know it's the one thing I wonder
about in terms of like okay we're not
blank slates was I just given ambition
like at a neurological level maybe
certainly possible I've made it bigger
and more all-consuming throughout my
life that is for sure I have just enough
stubbornness in me that growing up when
people told me I couldn't do something
part of my like every time someone told
me I couldn't do it I would say well I'm
gonna do it bigger you you you can't
even do this and let alone that then I'm
gonna do this and you know we ultimately
get to I'm building the nice Disney so
it's like there's externally driven then
some of it for sure but some of it is
everything in my life
is driven by how something makes me feel
and I really believe all you have in
this world is how you feel about
yourself when you're by yourself so in
that dark quiet night when you're all
alone do you feel good or not and so I
steer by that and when I start losing
sleep because something is stressing me
out or I think I handled something
poorly I have to correct that and what
are the tactics so part of this is you
have a belief system through which
everything is filtered so my thing is
okay belief system I can get good at
anything I set my mind to belief system
number two having your growth mindset is
the absolute ideal so that means that
just because I'm not good at something
now doesn't mean I can't become good at
it that I should only value myself with
being a learner I shouldn't worry about
being smart right good talented nothing
just the willingness to stare naked Liat
my inadequacies
so if I've done something and it's
making me feel badly about myself I
start running through those filters also
does this beating myself up is it moving
me towards my goal or away from it now a
little bit of beating yourself up
actually probably does move you towards
your goal because it kicks you in the
ass gets you moving taking it seriously
you're really thinking about it but then
too much of it begins to erode yourself
and so I have to balance like am I just
beating myself up and now I've taken it
too far and I'm losing sleep over
something I just need to let go and
focus on getting better instead of
punishing myself like just get better at
it so those those are the tactics that I
use the word yet is a huge tactic for me
Tom you suck
oh I'm not good at that yet okay cool
thank you got it I can get good at that
and and just keep coming back to those
very simple basic building blocks of my
belief system what I value where my
priorities lie well my goal is having
total clarity am I actually moving
towards it and then just really holding
yourself accountable to that without
damaging your self-esteem and how do you
apply those tactics day to day like what
is the actual process is it journaling
is it meditation is well give you the
one with well so I do meditate not every
day but I try that makes it sound like I
can't do it if I want to meditation
falls in a certain order in my priority
list and there are days where because
sleep in terms of time allocation is my
number one priority so I get as much
sleep as I need I haven't used an alarm
with any regularity in 15 years maybe a
little more
so that for me is number one so now if I
sleep longer than I expected less I have
an early morning meeting like today so I
slept longer than I expected and I had
an early morning meeting so now it's
like oh I've got a truncate working out
to me is more important than meditating
so working out happens first then if I
have time if I've worked out and have
time I'll meditate so my order goes
working out learning meditating so
depending on what the order is and the
order might flip if I'm like really in a
stressful period in my life or something
like that then I may make meditating the
priority because I'm not feeling good
so it's you got to have some you know
flexibility but because I know the order
that they go and like today I worked out
and I wasn't able to learn or met I did
a little bit of learning as I do in
transitional moments but I didn't get it
like sit down and really like clock some
time and what is the learning look like
almost reading in podcast but by reading
shout-out to audible I mean listening
but yeah I do almost exclusively all of
my reading is audible
you can speed it up to 3.5 X now that's
so sexy I can't even tell you like I had
lighted that I'd have to listen to it
again really no you can I don't know
that I could ridicu work your way yeah
for sure and what is the meditation
process specifically look like dead
simple so I use a what I call just
breathe so it was born of Mark Divine's
box breathing at least he was the one
that introduced it to me so he preaches
do it for equal parts so you've got the
inhale is the exact same length as the
inhale hold exact same length is the
exhale exact same length is the exhale
hold and I'm doing that made me feel out
of breath and just felt weird so what I
started doing was I'm going to maximize
the pleasure in each part of the breast
cycle so for me it happens to be a sort
of medium inhale a very short inhale
hold a rapid exhale I just let the air
out and then a very prolonged exhale
home and that rhythm feels awesome and I
do that for 10 or 15 minutes and I can
get into an alpha wave stay to feel calm
creative it just feels awesome that
that's one of those things that people
that haven't tried meditation or tried
it but never got to the part where it
feels awesome
my heart breaks for them it is a tool I
rejected for so many years because it
felt will see to me and remember I'm the
guy that had to learn to toughen up
so I feared that that was like backwards
momentum and so finally one marked
divine looked at me and was basically
like stop being an idiot and try this
and he's like this tough ass Navy SEAL
yeah I thought I'm gonna try and then it
changed my life
it's interesting that it took you that
long given your interest in
neuroplasticity and brain development
and being open-minded and all that yeah
I was as a learner I was more there's
two ways about it
right do you have a council of mentors
like who do you look to for advice and
guidance other than your wife it's
really books man books and podcasts so
you know like I have the very good
fortune of bringing on essentially a
mentor every week to come in and people
think of it as the hour that I spend
with them recording it's really the 12
hours I spend researching them that's
where it's like 12 hours in rich roles
world and then capping that with you
know an hour hour and a half where we
just get a talk get to know each other
like that's on a whole nother planet so
that that's really my mentorship these
days you have a very interesting
interest in longevity yes can you talk
about that a little yeah I want to live
forever I'm doing my best to plan to
live forever but here's I find this very
interesting and I'm way interested in
the potential blind spot that I'm
creating around how I should be acting
today given that as of right now I am
going to die so I'm very aware of that
it does not cause me emotional distress
to think that I'm dying so it's not I
don't spend a lot of time struggling
with it there are two types of people
there's move away and there's move
towards I'm not moving away from death
I'm moving towards living forever so I
don't have a fear of dying I think that
when I'm dead I'm dead and that's it I
don't think there's anything after that
I think it is a light that has been
turned off so now it's no spiritual
perspective on you at all if that's how
you define spiritual zero and I
personally think that's amazing so I I
think that the fact that life
one of my favorite quotes came from Phil
Jackson sounds very Buddhist to me
things come together things fall apart
now she's always so much right now my
atoms are
together one day they will fall apart
and cool I dig that about life there's
there's a sense of renewal that comes
with that and that's one thing I
struggle with we all start living
forever what happens to ideas so because
I think they will stagnate I don't think
most people push themselves so I think
there are there are problems with that
but because I love life because I
believe in a near infinite ability to
change and grow and adapt and because
I'm so excited about hard work and
struggle and building and creating and
connecting it's just it's just rad like
I can't imagine ever unless my life
became just pain then yeah I'd be like
no this doesn't make sense like tap out
well the idea of living forever as a
pure thought experiment is fascinating
because you would have to believe or
imagine that a huge percentage of the
population should this become an event
in eventualities
would suddenly be struck incredibly
risk-averse because the cost of taking a
risk is so high if you could perchance
live forever why would you skydive why
would you do any of these things that
would put that prospect in peril and I
think it would create mass paralysis for
a lot of people so this is really
fascinating and I think that would be
true for the next 50 years and then
after that will get to the point where
you can upload your consciousness or you
can and let's say you don't bind to 50
years 100 years a thousand years it will
happen so yes we may go through a period
of paralysis and and I think that is
utterly fascinating I would be one of
the paralyzed people every forever I
don't want to go outside
so until life became so mundane and it's
it's intolerable right the idea that the
prospect that you would live forever I
mean we can't even I don't think our
brains are plastic enough yeah to really
feel well so now you comprehend really
fascinating [ __ ] about like how much so
when I think about living forever
immediately assume I mean as a cyborg
because I really believe that we're
gonna begin augmenting our brains either
just by uploading our consciousness or
by augmenting our Wetworks
to the point where we have brain
computer interfaces Elon Musk says in
the next
God like six months he plans to make an
announcement that he thinks is gonna
shock people about the state of computer
brain interfaces so it's it's not here
today by any stretch of the imagination
but it's not far away so it's it's
certainly coming its measured in decades
not you know hundreds of years so that's
super trippy and super interesting to me
and how much of these things can we mess
with so like for instance you live
forever but you're not afraid to take
some amount of calculated risk and then
we have to ask the question how much of
the emotion that causes people to do
such dumb and hurtful stuff do we want
to get rid of any of it maybe none of it
maybe we accept that you're gonna get
mass shootings because some people go to
such a dark place and that it's better
off to have the mass shootings as tragic
and horrifying as they are or no maybe
we should get rid of those entirely and
not tolerate that I don't know man I am
not the person to answer those questions
I just want to be there for the debate
and this is what I find so interesting
it never occurred to me until I was on
Joe Rogan it never occurred to me that
some people don't want to live through
the apocalypse
I always thought everybody wants to be
the person on the other end and that was
the first person that was like no no I
don't want to be I don't want to make it
through I was like wow that that mindset
just never occurred to me that's
interesting well I think the thing that
is most appealing about that if I
entertain that concept which I haven't
spent a lot of time thinking about the
thing that appeals to me is the I mean
it's I'm somebody who time is my most
precious resource I'm always trying to
get more time it's the one thing that I
can't renew right and there just isn't
enough time to do all the things I want
to do what would life look like if
suddenly time was the most available
resource that one has there's a book
that covers this it is amazing have you
read Einstein's dreams no oh you'll love
it you will love it dude I'm telling you
so this whole book deals with like time
just like it's it's a totally fiction
book that just does a whole bunch of
thought experiments in narrative form
about different aspects of time and one
of them is
where everyone lives forever and the
world bifurcates into two kinds of
people I read this when I was like
somewhere between 12 and 14 it left such
a lasting impression on me it is why I'm
obsessed with living forever so I read
this story and he says the world
bifurcates in these two kinds of people
type a they do nothing because there's
always time to do it tomorrow time is so
infinite that they they never do
anything and then type B does everything
because they know there's time to get
truly great at everything they've ever
loved and I was like that's me that's my
camp there's so many things in this
world that I am absolutely in love with
passionate about let alone just
interested in but I don't have the time
and so my life is a constant triage of
having to say because they say 80% of
business is knowing what not to do it's
like I don't just want to build the next
Disney dude there's so many more things
that I find so interesting I want to
travel to Mars but I'm never gonna do it
because it's it takes me away from the
one thing I've had to say this is my
mission in life my mission in life is to
influence culture to give everyone an
empowering mindset what they do with the
empowering mindset but it's driven by a
sense of urgency if you remove that
sense of urgency I don't know that you
can really anticipate the downstream
impact on your internal Drive absolutely
true I'm willing to accept I'm
completely ignorant to that but from my
perspective today let me tell you how it
feels these are words super
intentionally so just doing the thought
experiment for me and I I've this is a
little cheeky to put it in this way but
I've lived through the moment where I
know what I would do when I have money
and I have to give it up to do something
and I choose the go do something that
makes me feel alive I've had the moment
where I've had all the money in the
world and I know what I do do I retire
and the answer is no I don't I keep
going as if I had urgency for what
though you could say oh to have the
impact to leave your legacy but I don't
think legacy at all in the slightest if
you told me Tom you could spend the next
40 years building the sink but no one
will ever know who you are
I'd be like fine does it does the impact
actually happen and carry on yes perfect
it is that experiment of thinking like
whoa we can actually make the world
better and that people go on to do
amazing things the only thing that
matters to me is what I think about it
it doesn't matter what other people
think about me that's irrelevant I can't
control
it's gonna change throughout my life it
just too many people have said if you
stay in the game long enough you will
see yourself become the villain so I
know like right now people come up to me
crying and thanking me for their help
I'm one sentence away from saying
something that really upsets people and
then people come in are like [ __ ] you I
hope you burn so it's like I get it I
know how that plays out so I don't care
about that it's beautiful when it's
positive and I've helped somebody
but I'm only worried about what I think
about myself so I know about myself
the thing that I'm moving towards is
really thinking that I'm making impact
and while it's possible that on a long
enough time line I will stop being
neurochemical II rewarded for that and
not care anymore and dust that might
slow down and not want to do anything
but nothing in my 42 years of experience
lead me to believe that that is true
about me so I am there's nothing there's
no shortage of things I'm so excited
about that the thing that scares me I
have two fears my wife dying because we
have this beautiful shared experience
and I don't want I don't want to try to
recreate that and it can only be
recreated in real time so it would take
me 18 years to get back what I have with
her and then the other thing is brain
damage because if I can't process data
the way that I process data now I worry
it won't be as fun so like the struggle
of everything the trying that's I value
myself for that and that's what I really
love and then just innately and I don't
know that I did anything to earn this I
love change so where other people are
freaked out by change dude I welcome
change aggressively the bigger the
shake-up the better so well that fear of
brain damage might have something to do
with your aversion of freediving oh that
is well the free diving is thalassemia
phobia that was a phobia this others
Alice Authority R of the the DIA so it
is a completely irrational fear of being
consumed by sharks or other gigantic
creatures of the deep there is something
that really freaks me out about how deep
and dark it is below you and this may be
as simple as I watch jaws and adjustment
scared me that much right but dude you
know that was something in the air you
know
how about where it's clear like in the
Caribbean or Lalo I swim out to where I
could get back within six seconds of
where I can put my feet on the ground
that's it that's it wow what a success
mean to you how do you define that
technique 1000% that's it that is all
that matters so building a set of skills
that was insanely hard to do but it
meant something to you to build it that
gave you the ability to do something you
care deeply about that allows you to
serve not only yourself but other people
that feeling which will survive through
moments of suffering hardship loss that
is all that matters that that's when you
feel good about yourself when you by
yourself
conversely how do you think about
failure then I'm not trying for me like
to not have the audacious goal to not
really give it a real shot and I know
I'm constantly gut checking myself for
am I playing at building the next Disney
or am I actually building the next
Disney that means something to me so if
I get to the end of this in the world is
clapping for me and they're like oh my
god you're so amazing and look how far
you went but I know that I was only
playing at trying to get there and then
I kept dialing it back because I was
getting too scared that that would be
failure for me yeah and what about the
difference between inspiration or
motivation and real impact
I love inspiration motivation but it is
the neurological equivalent of candy
it's rad it has its place but everyone
because those just happen to be fleeting
neurological States yeah you you just
have to find something that's way more
grounded you need a mission you need a
grand why you need to know what it is
and this is not a discovery it's a thing
you decide I decided now because I tell
it as a story people think oh it was
unavoidable he meets this kid rashon and
that coupled with all the people that he
worked with a quest it's sort of
inevitable that he decides that he's
going to build impact theory and try to
change culture to give everyone an
empowering mindset yeah well literally a
year before I decided to found impact
Theory my mission in life was to end
metabolic disease so it's like you
decide and then you point yourself at
something nothing is ever going to feel
right like this is what I was put on
earth to do
it won't feel that way until about a
year or two years after you've been
saying that's what you're gonna do that
that's where you're committed to and
actually acting in accordance with that
and then you'll be like yeah this
actually is my mission so people just
have to decide and start going - right
so when someone comes to you and says oh
my god look what you build it's so
inspiring but I don't know what my
purpose is I don't know what makes me
passionate I'm not sure which direction
to take like what is the counsel I'm
sure you filled this question all the
time like what is your counsel - that
info first and foremost
go play go discover like wander around
go to a different country like encounter
enough stuff that you see what actually
gives you that spark of interest don't
expect a spark of passion doesn't happen
like that you're gonna be interested by
something and that's something will be
maybe a little more interesting than the
next thing that thing now go down the
process of really engaging with it they
go full in so if you were traveling
around India and you went and taught a
you know a week-long math class and you
were like I've never been this fulfilled
in my life move to India and teaching
the slums for a year and even that were
how about just when you go back home
maybe you know start tutoring kit like
well you don't have to revolutionize
your life overnight but if you start
bringing greater expression to that
impulse it will lead you in a trajectory
that you can't foresee in that moment
super powerful answer so I'm a thousand
percent with that engaging with it
whatever face that takes but really
spending time is that really doing it
then if it turns into a full-blown
fascination we like I really dig this
then we're gonna go down the process of
gaining mastery only in the process of
gaining mastery will you find passion so
to me passion comes out of skylake love
I don't believe that love it needs a
different word unrequited love is a very
different neurological state than
reciprocal love so if you have
unrequited love to me that's something
you really like I love singing but I'm
[ __ ] at it so I have unrequited love I
love singing the singing does not love
me back now I could go down the process
of gaining mastery and then I may find
that I've a real passion for it because
part of its going to become
oh I'm gaining the skill and this skill
of singing allows me to have an
emotional impact not only on myself but
on other peope
I can make them feel good I can change
their mood I can tell a story whatever
it is that you want to do with the music
but when you're able to do with that and
you're truly good at it and it has the
outcome that you desire then it can
become a passion but to get a passion
you've got to fight through just
ridiculous amounts of boredom fatigue
everything to truly become good enough
at it that it's a skill that has utility
yeah people don't like that I mean two
observations the first is people want
the fast track superhighway to being
where somebody like you is they don't
see all the toil and the obstacles etc
that got you to this place and I think
secondary to that or perhaps the primary
thing really is commitment to self
understanding and self-knowledge such
that your your level of awareness is
adequately tuned so that when that
impulse arises you can recognize it but
if you're disconnected from your
yourself from your this meatsuit that
we're walking around in because you're
eating [ __ ] food and you're watching too
much television and you're just reacting
to your your environment 24/7 then when
that moment arises you're unlikely to
recognize it so there is a there's an
actualization process of commitment to
self I think that is required and it's
it's a it's an ephemeral concept but
that I think is the key to being able to
to act on that impulse when the moment
occurs for sure yeah because otherwise I
think we're all we are we're all visited
by these moments so the difference is
who is paying attention do you have like
the Silver Bullet for self awareness I
have a mechanism but I'm not sure that
it's very good I don't have a silver
bullet I think it's a long slog you know
I think it's a daily it's a daily
process and commitment to self
connection and and that's gonna look
different for for all different kinds of
people it can be yoga it can be
meditation it can be exercise it can be
reading it can be journal
can be any number of things but I think
carving out that time in that space to
focus inward in whatever way that
resonates with you I think it's crucial
to on that journey of self-discovery and
self-actualization yeah would you agree
I would and and as you were talking I
was like god this is a book with writing
and it's a book worth writing one
because I get asked about it all the
time - because you're right and it is so
fundamental and three because I don't
have the easy answer I'm not even sure
how I did it so it's like if somebody
gave you an easy answer I wouldn't trust
that answer yeah either but I want that
easy answer yeah of course we all do
right but you're absolutely right you
know but it would be fun to do that work
of figuring out what did I do
because I was me particulars very
unselfish of college and it had its
advantages for sure
because there were like I had I was
saying her that I didn't feel bullied
growing up but there was one kid who
came up to me after high school and
apologized for bullying me and I was
like bro I so like unselfie were making
fun of me it just didn't make my radar I
had a couple people I had those
conversations as well which is nice
which side were you on I was on that I
was the bullied yeah but I've had people
atone for that with me which essentially
yeah I wish that I had been like more
aware of it I was like wow how oblivious
was I so that was pretty crazy
yeah and are you gonna get back up and
do more standup I don't think so I know
it's not a driver for me so the thing is
it it never came from a place of like oh
I have some sucking wound that can only
be saved by you know getting that
adulation from people I loved it it was
fun it was it was something I got very
good at and I enjoyed making people
laugh and but I the the truth of the
matter is I'm living room funny I'm not
staged funny and to get staged funny I'd
really have to put work into it so when
like it to me it's far more interesting
and the funny thing is now so many years
of like letting that
so atrophy I it's not like a go-to thing
for me I don't have the jokes like
they're plus I only ever knew how to be
self-deprecating
so my funny came from when I was just a
story teller so I wasn't like like Mitch
Hedberg told jokes I don't have jokes so
it was just like let me tell you about
my first prostate exam that was one of
my best bits [ __ ] hilarious but that
was it's just a story well that's
incompatible with how you live your life
now somebody who's very intent about the
language that you use about yourself
right very very very very yeah I've
noticed you catching yourself a couple
times even today throughout this
conversation where there's a bit of
negative self-talk creeping up and then
you course-correct it yes so what is
that relationship between language and
manifestation I think it's I think it's
massive I don't think that thinking
something or saying something makes it
true but I think that thinking something
and saying something makes you believe
it and the things you believe you will
unintentionally guide yourself towards I
think your belief about yourself and
what you're capable of influences your
accomplishments more than you can
imagine just because you don't put in
the extra mile of effort or whatever
that it was going to take because you
don't believe that you can or you don't
even allow yourself to dream it and if
you don't dream it you're never going to
come up with a plan so it is wildly
influential in terms of what happens
just not in a mystical way in a very
like tactical you just end up either
doing or not doing the things you should
yeah I mean if anybody doubts that I
challenge you to take a week and write
down all of your internal self-talk
every thought that you have as it occurs
and most people would be shocked at the
internal dialog that we all have with
ourselves I had to do so much work and
it's still such a challenge to overcome
a lot of that negative speak that goes
on in my head can we dig into something
fascinating yeah because I have the
luxury of seeing you from the outside
and not the inside
that's so weird to me now I get it I
believe you because I'm exactly the same
so I have all this negative self-talk
and it's like god what do I have to do
and accomplish for that voice to fall
silent and the answer is it will never
fall silent I'm not even sure I wanted
to but looking
our program a thousand percent it's so
interesting to me looking at you from
the outside being around you makes me
feel some kind of way and that some kind
of way is more at ease spiritual is the
wrong word but that's like the vibe like
there's just like depth that like sort
of hums off of you like somebody who's
knows something that you want and it's
it's people say that to me and I know
there was some feedback from me doing
your show on that level like oh he's so
chill but I that's not how I feel that's
the fascinating part and that's what the
reason that I really stopped to put a
finger on this is I want people to
understand that you feel like rich but
you may look like rich to other people
where people are like whoa like you've
really got stuff together and once you
can come to terms with oh this is the
nature of being a human the nature of
being a human is the brain developed on
mechanism over millions of years of
evolution to pitch up this negative
stuff and you don't have to believe it
it is merely meant to keep you safe
so you may hear it as one of the voices
but when it's the only voice you're
inherently in trouble and so people
think they've done something wrong that
they are a bad person because they have
this negative voice that's beating the
[ __ ] out of them
but the reality is that voice is is a
mechanism it's like being mad that you
have a second arm
it's like learn how to use it well it
requires you to distinguish and I don't
know how you feel about this with your
perspective on spirituality but I look
at it like the brain is bifurcated
between the thinking brain and your
higher consciousness or higher state of
thinking your unconscious mind and this
you know thinking mind can run rampant
and run all of these narratives and we
think we don't have control over that or
we identify that with our higher
consciousness and understanding that
these are separate and distinct from
each other and also understanding that
you actually can control that thinking
mind and you can decide whether you're
going to pay attention to it or not is I
think the first step
and recalculating that story and taking
greater control over how you think and
behave mm yeah most I know and it's it's
it's almost like you have to play a
trick on yourself and for people that
that have have trouble understanding
that just imagine you're having an
amazing dream and in that dream you're
having a conversation with somebody and
that person says something to you that
you did not anticipate well your brain
came up with that in the deep recesses
of your unconscious mind that was
conjured up without your awareness of it
and I think that should give you a
glimpse of the complexity of this thing
and we're all walking around with
stories stories we tell ourselves about
ourselves and who we are and I think we
vastly underestimate the power of those
stories to shape the lives that we
ultimately end up leading and if you can
take control of that story and change
that story as a storyteller your life
will change more dramatically than
people can imagine yeah all right well
let's wrap this up with with one little
final inquiry here
for the person who's stuck for the guy
or gal who's in the cubicle whose hates
their job is in a dysfunctional
relationship is in debt whatever the
case may be desperately wants a way out
a way forward a lifeline where does that
process begin for you like what is the
advice that you give that person so it
begins with believing or acknowledging
that humans are the ultimate adaptation
machine so the the thing that has made
us the apex predator is not that we're
stronger it's not even that we're
smarter in fact the the quote often
attributed to Darwin is that oh it's a
survival of the fittest he actually
didn't say that what he did say was it's
not the strongest of the species that
survives nor the most intelligent but
rather the most adaptive to change now
the reason that humans are the apex of
all apex is is because we are the most
adaptive species to change so if you
know that then it becomes infinitely
less important who you
or today and what matters is who do you
want to become and what price and the
price being the time and energy that
you're gonna put into acquiring the
skills to become that person so imagine
the person that you want to be how would
they act and then start acting like that
if the person that you want to be would
leave their job and you know regardless
of whether they had a safety net burn
the ships and go after something new
then that's what you should do if the
person that you want to be would start
working nights and weekends because they
very much value having a stable income
that they can provide for their family
or themselves whatever but are going to
be disciplined and spend nights and
weekends to get the skill set to go be
more valuable somewhere else or to start
their own company whatever then do that
so there are a thousand ways to make
your life what you want it to be without
even changing your circumstance you
could just like you were just talking
about change the framing the perspective
from which you tell your story in fact
now I will tell you my film school story
from both angles there too this is the
facts of what happened I applied to USC
but didn't realize you had to apply to
USC film school separately so I get into
USC but I have terrible SAT scores I
took a nine ninety or I took it twice
and I got a nine ninety combined score
it's terrible they do it differently now
so people realize just how bad at school
sucks actually that was atrocious and so
when I looked at the film school it
required a 1,300 and so I was like whoa
how am I supposed to get in I go see the
school counselor at USC and they say
listen Tom stop because I was taking
film classes the general education
classes they said immediately stop
taking those classes you are not going
to get into film school not words like
that those words they said statistically
speaking you're more likely to get into
Harvard Law than you are to get into USC
film school the number of people that
apply is ungodly the number of slots are
tiny you're not going to get in you're
gonna end up spending a fifth year here
because you will have wasted your time
and I said okay I'm going to get in
thank you very much the stubbornness in
me so if you say I can't I'm going to
and I said there's got to be a way to
figure this out and I found out that one
of the teachers that was on the
admissions committee would let you join
him for lunch
so I joined him for lunch and as much as
I can't believe this no one else did it
was just me and so I'm sitting down with
him and I'm like all right look dude
here's the situation I want to get into
film school but I got a 990 on my SATs
he was like Tom what does SAT stand for
and I said scholastic aptitude test he's
like that's correct it's meant to tell
me how well you're gonna do in college
so there are two admissions periods one
as you're coming into college in which
case I care deeply about your SATs and
then the other is as an incoming junior
he said you've already missed the
freshman window so your SATs don't
matter anymore what I want to see is how
good of grades can you get because that
tells me how well you're actually doing
in college he said I don't care if
you're already a good filmmaker we want
to make you a good filmmaker I just need
to know you know how to learn so he said
get good grades
so I locked myself in my dorm for the
next two years I didn't drink
I didn't party I didn't date I didn't do
anything but study and I studied like a
beast and at the end of those two years
either had a four point or like a 395
something crazy and so I got into film
school so now I'm like alright
[ __ ] I told you I was gonna get
in I got in and I did it in a clever way
I wouldn't ask the guy what I had to do
he told me I did it for two years I was
crazy disciplined and it worked man and
I'm here there are three production
classes that you have you've got a 290 a
310 and you crew a 480 which is a senior
thesis film so I do my 290 they're
pretty good I start getting attention
for my filmmaking
so in 290 people like wow this kid he's
kind of one to watch because my two my
two 90s were so good for 3:10 you have
to partner with somebody now you have to
either be a director or a
cinematographer now needless to say
everybody wants to be a director but
then if you're not going to be a
director or sorry if you're gonna be a
director you want to get the best
cinematographer and so what ends up
happening is the people that can't get a
cinematographer end up being
cinematographers so a lot of times like
people sort of make do I wanted to be a
director and one of the other best
directors wanted to be a cinematographer
so now everybody wanted him as their
cinematographer and he chose me so now
I've been one to watch into 90 I get the
ideal partner for 3:10 and we kill or
how did you get
that guy he thought I was talented fun
to be around and that I was one to watch
and so in terms of I would be a good
person to partner with in order to get a
good 480 so partners with me and we kill
it and we don't make the classic mistake
that most student filmmakers make which
is to tell a feature-length film as a
you know silent film so we told a very
short moment in time as a silent baka
web film where you wouldn't expect
people to talk anyway so it didn't feel
like a silent film so people love it
does very well we both get top level
crewing positions on a 480 we both crush
that and both of us actually end up
getting selected only four people get
chosen for a 480 and we both got
selected to direct to 480 so now I go
from you're never getting into film
school kid you're more likely to get
into Harvard Law than USC film to being
one of only four people to not only get
in but direct the senior thesis film so
right I'm killing it with Tom what are
you talking about you failed at film
school baby you did everything you were
one to watch and I was like man I'm
making it I'm gonna graduate I'm gonna
get my three picture deal this is gonna
be amazing I'm naturally talented I knew
it
everything has proven to me that I have
natural talent as a filmmaker fixed
mindset all day but who cares baby
because I got the talent then I go into
the 480 as a director and I [ __ ] it up
and I crash and burn so spectacularly
that people are taking snippets of my
film and cutting them into what we would
now call memes but at the time was just
like mean to be funny and they would
like screen it in front of the class
people would be pissing their pants with
laughter because it was so bad
and I was having like basically an
emotional breakdown and I called my mom
from the middle of the school I'm laying
on the ground on a payphone and I'm like
my life is over and I'm gonna graduate
now from film school with no senior
thesis that I can show anybody and this
is a point in filmmaking there's no like
digital filmmaking no-one's ever made a
film on digital before that doesn't
exist if you want to shoot a film
minimum for a no budget films a hundred
thousand dollars that might as well been
a hundred million dollars so I graduate
I steal my master by the way which I
still have because it is that bad I know
when people hear this story they just
think I'm being humble
I'm telling you just like you over my
[ __ ] dead body oh come on everybody
slurring I've told the story many times
I don't I think my wife has seen it but
only once so yeah
over my dead body the thing will never
be seen although I have to admit like at
some point maybe it'd be cool to show
one once I have something that I'm that
I've done that I'm proud of I might show
it you could make that part when you
give when you give presentations just
show a clip of it yeah you're absolutely
right anyway so no not at all so I steal
the master because that bad and I never
want people to see it and I graduate and
now I feel lost and I'm like I'm never
gonna break in my life is like I had one
shot I actually made it and I totally
mess it up and so it's over I'm never
gonna be a filmmaker and that was my
identity I was a filmmaker and so now
that was gone and I was like wow I don't
know what to do and so I was sliding
towards depression I would lay on my the
floor of my unfurnished apartment so I
couldn't afford to furnish it and I
remember the feeling of the vinyl carpet
smashing into my face because I would
just lay there for our two hours at a
time and I was like yep my life is over
I don't know what to do I'm sliding
towards depression and thankfully I
started reading about the brain to avoid
sliding towards depression so now there
are two ways to look at my film career
one is dude against all odds you became
through hard work and discipline not
because anything was given to you people
told you would never do it and you
worked and worked and worked and you got
it and you did it and you were one of
the four people selected to do a 480 and
the amount even though you're 40 wasn't
good the amount that you learned from
that 40 transformed you not just as a
filmmaker as a human being and became
one of the most transformative
revolutionary things to set you up
that's real that story is there and what
you just heard the other story is you
got arrogant you got cocky you believed
you were the next John Woo that you
could roll up on set that you were
naturally gifted you didn't have to work
so you hardly broke your script at all
you like I wrote the script in like an
hour before having to turn it in to be
considered I never touched it again
until the first day of shooting didn't
storyboard nothing just welled up and
thought I'll know where to put the
camera it'll all just feel instinctive
in
intuitive and so I went and nothing was
working it was all garbage my crew
didn't believe in me the film was
falling apart teachers try to save me
but couldn't get through to me because I
was so convinced I know what I'm doing
and it just turned into a pile of
garbage because I have no talent now
both of those scenarios are true it is
true that at that time I did not have
Talent
now it doesn't mean I couldn't develop
skill but I didn't have talent so which
do you which story do you repeat to
yourself for the first probably two
years after I graduated I repeated that
I'm not talented story then I began
reading about the brain and realized oh
I just haven't developed skills yet and
so then I began change the story and to
focus on the discipline and all the
things that I've learned and all that
but both are true and so what I tell
people is because you're more likely to
believe something negative don't even
worry about what's true worry about what
empowers you when it comes to just
yourself and not talking about you know
a fake news or you know a post truth
world I'm just saying for yourself
there's both of those narratives are
based on facts so the truth of one or
the other doesn't matter one is
empowering and one is disempowering act
in accordance with the one that's
empowering it's a great place to end it
did powerful there it is boom awesome
how do you feel feel great dude anytime
I'm hanging out with you I'm a happy man
yeah thanks for bringing the heat today
my pleasure I loved it
if you're digging on Tom and impact
Theory he's a easy guy to find on the
Internet
if you just if probably if you type in
Tom on Google it'll it'll pull up your
stuff I don't know if I'm that cool yet
but you type in Tom B I yeah so impact
theory on youtube on itunes wherever you
enjoy your narrative storytelling
empowering content you can find him at
tom bill you on twitter and instagram as
well yes yes you have any good
interviews you're excited about that are
coming up well I will say if they
haven't heard yours it's always cool to
see the roles reversed so I highly
recommend that episode which I think you
know amazingly well that's good
we've got our David Goggins episode -
that one's gonna be huge
I've already recorded that yeah yeah
he's coming over here pretty soon
- amazing good amazing so yeah he's he's
evolved as a person he'll bring that
it's just phenomenal exciting mom so
yeah I'm super amped on that one cool
all right man come back and talk to me
again
anytime cool peace
[Music]
you